Okay.
We're alive.
What's up dude?
I'm doing fantastic referendums,
ladies and gentlemen.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Hey Buddy.
Hey,
a meeting.
If you told me six,
seven years ago that I was going to be on the Joe Rogan podcast or the Joe Rogan
show out,
I told you no way in hell.
Well,
it didn't exist.
So that's,
you go to Colorado.
You don't have to find me.
You'd have to go,
dude,
I got an idea.
Yeah.
There's this thing called podcasting.
You're going to love it,
but there's no way I would've thought I would be doing this either six,
seven years ago.
So we're in the same boat.
Love it,
man.
There you go,
And now did you like we were talking to Pacquiao,
Mayweather fight before we,
before we came on air.
Uh,
did you actually watch it?
Yes.
Yeah,
I watched it as a fight guy.
What a,
what were your thoughts on it?
I'm sure you've covered this already,
so I'm sorry if you're going to make you repeat things,
you know,
I'm not in the minority.
I actually enjoyed it.
I really,
yeah,
I enjoyed it from like a technical standpoint and if like two guys who are the
best in the world trying to figure each other out.
Yeah.
And now do you think that as a guy that knows the fight game,
you can respect defense more than your average fight fan?
We'll definitely more than my wife.
Oh my God.
She was saying some retarded shit.
She was,
she was saying you should have to get knocked down in order to win.
I go,
what are you talking about?
She goes,
that's that way it would at least be exciting.
So like make them go for guaranteed concussion,
satellite Charon,
shit like that.
Like,
so ridiculous.
It's like hearing like some people like I kinda get it.
She's not a fight fan like silver,
her watching it,
it's just boring as fuck.
Cause just two dudes not hitting each other.
And then when one dude gets close to the do,
grabs him,
you know?
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
I,
I love watching hockey on TV.
That's like my favorite sport to watch on TV.
And hockey is notoriously awful right on TV and people hate it on TV.
I love it because I played for like five years when I was a kid.
So like I recognize that they're setting up plays,
I recognize strategies and stuff like that.
So what I'm trying to explain to people and there's like this is stupid or not
scoring,
I can't follow the puck and I'm trying to like,
I'm trying to tell them the ins and outs of it and I'm sure the fight game is
like that for you.
Do they still have that thing where they follow the puck like a with a circle or
they try them for a while.
Not that on Fox it was like,
and it turns slap shots into a comet.
Like it.
Like it just had this like red trail behind it.
Really?
Yeah.
And like it was,
it was supposed to get like the casual fan into it,
but it's like no one is going to hate hockey and then see a comet trail on the
puck and go,
well now I'm in,
I got this now.
Well,
they've done some weird shit like that with football,
right,
with graphics and all the amazing part is that I was a huge fan of the XFL.
If people remember the Xfl,
that was Vince Mcmahon's thing.
And then a lot of the stuff that they did are,
is now being implemented into the NFL.
What kinds of stuff?
Like the overhead camera that is like on strings and that follows the game from
the top.
That was XFL.
Uh,
thou,
thou is XFL before,
uh,
trying to make a,
I mean they tried to make kickoffs more exciting until like all the concussion
stuff came out.
But yeah,
like there's a few things and certainly making it more,
Vince at least recognized that it would be more fun if there was like complex
storylines and like you knew like the soap opera of it much like he did for
wrestling.
So now you see the NFL and it's the world's greatest reality show.
Like they,
like they follow the guys off the field and like they get into their lives and
now it's what the Xfl was where like they're trying to build up rivalries and
you know what players actually don't like each other and who slept with who his
wife and things like that.
You know,
the problem with getting into the NFL life,
like getting into the player's life is like,
you're trying to pretend that these guys are not the savage gladiators who were
just smashing people every day.
Yeah.
And you want them like off field to be like the sweeties like baking pies and
hugging their kids.
Know.
It's like you don't get a guy like Ray Lewis.
Yeah.
Without Him.
Like did you see the video of him pleading to the people of Baltimore going,
no,
violence is not the answer.
And he's like,
whole life dude.
He's so intense.
Like yet.
Okay.
So if violence isn't the answer,
move out of your mansion.
Cause that's what built the mansion was violence.
People know who you are.
Yeah.
You're super violent.
That's like,
that's like you and me saying like,
don't tell jokes.
Yeah.
Stop it wasn't he on trial for murder?
I mean that's been violent,
but he didn't really do it.
It was like one of his entourage and he was an a or allegedly accessory to
murder was college.
It was kind of like the snoop Dogg thing,
right?
Yeah.
Either way he's a football player.
Like,
like when you see like these fighters are these football players and see them
doing ridiculous shit and people get all surprised.
It's like you can't ask them to be anything other than what they really are.
Exactly.
You want that result.
You write that ray rice result,
you're going to get a ray rice,
you're going to get that happening.
Which is,
yeah.
Which is not saying we condone it.
I don't know.
But it's just saying don't be surprised when it happened,
but you can't.
All the sudden and 2015 start putting cameras on these guys,
following him around and expecting them to have exemplary behavior.
What they're good at is when the fucking place starts.
They're good at getting shit done,
you know,
and the way you do that is through violence,
explosive athleticism,
smashing in it.
Thanks fucking diving through mounds of enormous steroid it up,
dude.
Yeah.
And then with so much testosterone boiling over and then when Richard Sherman
gives an interview late last year or two or two years ago when he was like,
what the crap she can be put on me,
crap,
she's a punk.
Then they start getting mad at him.
Like how?
How dare you talk to Erin Andrews like that?
Oh,
oh,
petite white woman and you're just getting angry.
Why are you so angry?
Because he just play football for an hour.
That's why he's angry and that's why he's good at what he does.
Yeah.
The idea that you wanted Tim to take it from 10 all the way down to one again
and then just like come off like he's an Oscar Wylde play like,
well that's be,
we're all in the field of battle.
Might I tell you it was quite an interesting route.
That one.
Now it's not going to happen though those guys,
those guys are going to be too intense.
It's not fair.
I mean it's,
everybody wants everything sanitized.
I mean we want to make,
we want the purity of the sport,
but then we also want it to be fan friendly.
We also want it to be easily absorbed by the casual person who's watching it.
Yeah.
And you know this because you've had to interview guys right after they fight.
They're fired up after they've just been punched in the face and they are,
and that's literally the most testosterone probably that can run through your
body in a three minute period just like getting revved up and then you,
and then Joe Rogan comes in and puts a microphone and explain what happened out
there and then you will like,
they expect these guys to get like a complex thing.
People wonder why athletes,
they get mad that they always have those textbook answers.
Like one game at a time.
I was just doing a play.
It played a time where you'd go back and work examine,
they have those scripted answers so they don't have to think about giving those
answers because they can't in those moments.
Well not only that,
a lot of people are just not that good talking on camera.
Like that's something you've got to get relaxed at.
We forget because we talk for a living and that's what our normal is.
Our normal is talking in front of a bunch of strangers and being funny on a
moment's notice,
rather be in an interview or a radio show or a podcast,
whatever,
just,
hey,
flip the switch.
Go.
Right.
The average person does not do that.
Like when they have an actor give a speech at an awards show and it's like
something crazy happens and they have to be spontaneous.
It's like no,
they're actors.
A lot of times they can't do that.
Yeah.
A lot of them can.
And some of them can.
Like one of the best interviews ever was Mickey Rourke when he won some like
Golden Globe or one of those fucking,
whatever the name of you.
I think all wars are stupid.
I don't pay attention to any of that shit.
You award far faked it better than this faker.
But I mean now people do great performance,
but his,
uh,
he did this amazing speech where he was just so loose and relaxed talking all
kinds of crazy shit.
It was like one of the best speeches ever and it was,
it was fun cause he seemed like real comfortable in his own skin despite all the
craziness of that guy has been through and yeah.
Yeah.
It's always,
and that can go either way.
Like people either freak out with the honesty of that person or that were where
it's really refreshing.
Uh,
is,
is this,
is that it was a spirit of beard award,
so it wasn't me.
It was really what's really crazy too.
It's like you see him in this video and we'll play a little bit of it and then
you see him now.
Like now he looks like an old gypsy woman.
He's got a crazy doctors face up and it's actually an image that says chips
Mickey Rourke,
old Gypsy woman.
And that's exactly what it looks like.
Listen to some of this.
Thank you all very much.
Like look,
he's so happy.
Yeah.
I just want to say one thing about Eric Roberts.
Eric Roberts is probably the best actor I've ever worked with.
And I don't,
I don't know why in the last 15 years,
ain't nobody give him a chance to show his shit again because whatever he did
15,
20 years ago should be forgiven.
And I wish,
no,
um,
God damn series about that.
Eric Roberts is the fucking man.
Love it.
That's just one part of it.
And he gets loose
slightly.
Yeah,
I have.
He didn't like,
I like God,
God,
he deserves a second chance.
And I wish there'd be one goddamn film maker in this room that would,
would let him fly because the man,
he is something else.
Thank you,
Eric.
Eric will probably be arrested by the end of the day,
but uh,
anyway,
um,
and that little blonde dude that did that thing,
I'm going to beat erasure.
I get Outta here.
Well,
you're right.
He's very loose.
See,
she's like,
whatever nice to be presented,
it gets better.
Like he gets down to three.
I don't know what you do,
honey.
These two are really good.
Really good.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
uh,
I,
I've just gotten it
thousands of letters it shed from my people,
strangers and people that know me about,
about my dog that died six days ago.
Loki.
Hello.
Okay.
Is what people who don't have kids do you get all torn up about their dogs.
Right.
And I just got done talking to the Santa Monica Police Department.
They gave me a bed to sleep in 10 years ago and uh,
I thank them for,
I absent for two pillows they told me to fuck off.
But anyway,
uh,
it's like this kind of a speech for believing in me.
This is right after he did the wrestler.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Which damn,
that was a good movie.
People in the basil directors like Darren Aronofsky come around every 25 years,
the same way,
like Chimino Coppola,
Parker,
Adrian Line,
all the rest of them.
And I said 25 years that you wish you were in my year 30.
Uh,
and uh,
the only thing I want to say to any young actor or any activity gets an
opportunity to work with Darren.
You better be in shape because he will break you down.
He is one tough son of a bitch and he don't like it when I say that cause he
goes make,
he'll scare all the other actors away from me.
But Darren,
you know what,
if they ain't got the balls that bring it then fuck them.
You know.
Anyway,
I want to thank uh,
love this guy.
Yeah,
but now,
okay,
so go from there and look at the image of him now.
Pull up,
uh,
Mickey Rourke,
old Gypsy woman.
Just,
just,
just Google Mickey Rourke,
old Gypsy woman.
I would just always wonder like,
what the fuck happens to dude's or women or you know like that,
that Gowe um,
the fuck's her name?
Renee Zellweger right?
That's not even,
no,
there's that one right there.
Yeah,
this one.
Look at that.
What's gone well,
what does that she,
I said she,
I said she on instincts because like he,
he looks like his name should be Mildred right there.
Like,
just like,
it's that whole like everything's crazy about that.
The wig is crazy.
The face is crazy.
It's like poor bastard pulled back so he could see his hair.
He's wearing this crazy hair piece.
Then is he trying to look like or an old gypsy woman or is that just no,
that's,
he was at the fights.
That was,
he was at the UFC and he was upset.
One of the decisions and that was the face that he made,
but he's done something to his lips.
Apparently.
You're right.
He looks like the character from the Stephen King movie a thinner that Gypsy
woman that like rubbed her hand on the face like CNN.
Yeah.
That's her.
Wow.
So,
well,
I mean him and uh,
Bruce Jenner could hang out and just talk shit.
I think he's trying to be a woman though.
I think now he's not going crazy.
I mean,
that's what you do.
You think like that's what this business does to people that as they age,
whether it be Renee Zellweger or a Mickey Rourke are now,
there's some pictures out there I think of,
I think it's Ooma Thurman where it's like Huma Thurman's gotten,
I think they did some plastic surgery.
I think she did some plastic surgery to her and it's just something where you're
built up has like sort of either a sex symbol or whatever for so long and then
it just goes,
it starts to fade away then does that fuck with your head?
It would imagine,
I mean someone described beauty as a short live tyranny and I think beauty is
like a really hard one because some women they go from being unbelievably
desirable and then through no fault of their own,
just,
just father time natural agent.
They become monsters.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What's going on there?
She do.
Uh,
she pulled my God does she do,
she pulled some stuff back.
She doesn't look like her.
No,
she uh,
she looks like she's a character from that new movie.
Uh,
uh,
x Maki not done is weird man.
Right.
So weird.
And did she,
what did she do?
I'm trying to figure out what she did maybe.
Is that just to her wearing no makeup except for lipstick?
I have,
I have no idea.
I'm not,
I believe it or not,
I'm not a plastic surgeon.
A lot of feeling that if you added like see like one of them has all the slips,
all of his eye makeup on and the other one doesn't.
That's a big thing with gals.
Like you ever see a woman who doesn't have,
I make Alan,
you'd always hear with eye makeup on and then one day you don't,
you're like,
who are you?
Who are you?
Yeah.
You're fucking different humans.
The Huffington post and you might want to porn stars.
Yeah.
The porn stars without makeup thing.
That blew my mind.
It's a trip because then you see these girls without makeup,
like when the makeup on,
they are goddesses and you're just seeing them on the screen.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
That's like the ideal.
And then you see them without the makeup.
You're like,
oh,
I know eight girls from Riverside that looked just like that.
It's nuts.
Yeah.
You could do some amazing shit with makeup if you're a chick.
Or like there's a,
there was also a story about a dude.
He's makeup artists.
He like,
he's,
I think he's a black guy and he showed that with makeup.
He could look like Kim Kardashian and he put makeup on his face and at the end
of it you're like,
yeah,
that let me grant.
It looks like a madame Tussauds like wax museum,
Kim Kardashians.
But that's,
you look like that.
Like you created that and then he hit his face without,
it is not like that at all.
Obviously it looks or a weird thing.
Right?
It's like you didn't ask for it,
you didn't work for it.
No.
And just boom,
like in it,
it's an old debate.
Would you rather have all the looks and then slowly lose them or would you
rather be like,
uh,
Jason Alexander,
that looks the exact same as he did 30 years ago,
but he's going crazy too.
He's wearing it to pay now.
Yeah.
Jason Alexander put it to play on.
It's like he's like a walking episode of Seinfeld sign for,
there was an episode of Seinfeld where he wore a toupee and it was like,
it was,
it was really awkward.
It was really obvious and now he's kind of trying to do it.
I mean,
I don't blame guys to do the,
the,
the plugs or anything like that.
I don't blame them.
Hell,
a Wayne Rooney,
the,
uh,
soccer player did it and everyone knew that he had plugs and he's like,
I don't care.
I hear now.
I did it.
But you know what happens man first when you get a scar in the back of your
head.
So I have like a permanent smile on the back of my head and then second of all,
if the rest of your hair falls out the way I described it as like taking healthy
people and moving them into a neighborhood where everyone is dying,
the other hair falls out.
It's like
they haven't figured it out yet.
Like lips,
like when girls get their lips done,
you don't want to be an early adopter of that.
You don't want someone fucking with your face permanently.
Yeah.
This is the,
uh,
I think,
it was it the bill bourbon.
It was a bill.
A bill burr is a great bit about this where he's like,
yeah,
just wait until they,
until they fucking fix it.
Like wait,
wait until they get it right.
Like,
like the people that are going into plastic surgery right now,
like wait there,
they can't wait because they're 50 and they're like,
fuck,
you know,
I just want to look at 37 you know what,
there's like some doctors nail it though.
That's,
that's the,
the other problem is some doctors can do a really good job of making look a
little bit better.
It's those guys that go crazy and it's also like a girl,
like,
Ooh,
my Thurman.
I mean,
how much shopping around does she do for a plastic surgeon if she even got
plastic surgery or the other one Renee Zellweger,
do they just go with someone that he could trust like that they know?
Do they ask?
I mean,
and that's the thing is we talk about all the ones that went wrong because the
ones that went right,
we don't know this.
We're just like,
oh,
they look great.
A ton that went right,
right.
I mean,
I don't know who,
but like Christy Brown,
well,
she says she never had anything done.
She's like 61 or something like that.
She's still hot as fuck.
Yeah.
That,
I don't know what that is.
Or like genetics or you see a Sophia Loren,
he even when she was 60,
65,
you're like,
yeah,
well done.
Good for you.
Well who is the other one?
Raquel Welsh.
She's like deep deep into her seventies and she's still hot as fuck.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's just,
it's the,
just the genetic lottery I guess,
or let orally that like,
you know,
cause hey,
uh,
some people are,
are born and they've got like the natural like boat,
like Bo Jackson and where,
where they say like,
just natural athlete,
like God given talent or Herschel Walker just did pushups and sit ups his entire
damn life supposedly.
And then not sure I buy that.
Cause he also said that he only eats like a salad and soup the whole day,
whole day,
which doesn't even make any sense.
And then he also has multiple personality disorder or trauma induced multiple
personality disorder.
So who knows which Herschel list is a one her,
she might be doing roids squats.
We mean if anybody can talk about genetic lottery,
right.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Yeah.
Cause I mean it could for people don't know if people aren't listening to this
are people,
a lot of people were just listening to us.
Yeah.
You know,
explain,
uh,
am a,
Chondra plastic dwarf and that's the type of dwarfism that I have.
What does that mean?
Uh,
cause there's over a hundred types of dwarfism.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Well,
cause it's a genetic mutation.
So you have slight differences in how,
in how the gene,
uh,
changes.
So there were literally some dwarves out.
There's some little people that it's only like one of three people in the entire
world that have that specific type of dwarfism.
One of three in the whole world.
Well,
what are the differentiations?
like,
okay,
for me,
a Achondroplasia is what I have.
It's the most common type of dwarfism,
um,
minus characterized by small arms,
small legs,
prominent buttocks.
I love that one.
Uh,
prominent buttocks in large forehead,
uh,
collapsed nose bridge,
average size torso.
So like when we're sitting down,
we're making eye contact right now,
but I'm four foot for your six.
You're,
yeah,
you're,
you're five,
eight.
So yeah.
But there's some,
there's some dwarves that have a completely different body type.
Like,
like Vern Troyer who played many meeting Austin Powers movies.
He's got dwarfism,
but it's a completely different type of dwarfism.
When that guy was on celebrity,
what was that show?
Oh,
a surreal life.
Yeah.
Oh that was so sad.
I do a perfect impression of,
of,
of him drunk when he's,
uh,
when he's a pissing in the corner,
he made a noise.
Oh,
ah.
Oh.
Ah.
Is he still alive?
Yeah,
he's still alive.
That guy seemed like he was drinking himself to death,
you would think.
I mean,
hey,
he's still ticking man.
That's amazing.
And he's still alive.
It's hardcore for a guy like that too because he goes and he gets this big
movie,
he becomes a celebrity like almost instantaneously.
And then after that it kind of dries up and no one wants to see him humble laser
anymore.
So that what you got.
And it's weird cause I,
I saw that and when I was trying to into show business,
that's one of the reasons why I love being a standup comic.
Cause no matter what,
I could always go on stage and talking from an audience and be and be funny.
I can do that.
Like,
and there's only a few amount of people that can actually do that.
So as long as I got that skill,
I'm good.
I don't have to wait until the producer says,
yes,
I'll put you in a movie.
Yes,
I'll put you on a TV show it.
Well,
to answer your earlier question,
I think that's what makes people go crazy out here.
Like does the business do it to them?
What goes crazy is that they,
they're not in control,
their own destiny.
So if they do have any sort of success whatsoever,
if anything does take off for them,
it's like they're like,
oh,
it's,
it's happening,
it's happening.
It's like it's all out of their control,
right?
You audition for things,
get the job,
you're on the set.
It's like,
when is this going away?
And you've got to cultivate your career.
So they have to be very careful about the things that they say and yeah,
absolutely.
So yeah.
And that's one reason.
It's like light.
Like I said,
I love being a comic.
It's I,
no matter,
no matter what,
I always have that if,
because,
yeah,
I've had,
I've had a ton of auditions for TV shows that I haven't gotten.
Thanks Peter.
Dinklage ah,
fuck that guys changed the games.
Amazing.
He's changed the game.
He's so fucking good.
He's the,
he's the main guy and I'd show he's the dude and it's the biggest movie ever,
the biggest show rather ever.
And that show is one of the most impactful shows ever.
And a dwarf is really the big guy.
And I love that.
And the fact that,
yeah,
they talk about like can being a dwarf in the show,
but it's not the focus.
I love that.
It's just like the,
he talked about now off man,
it was what's beautiful about what he does in his character and that show is he
utilizes it to his advantage and he,
he lets people underestimate him because ultimately,
yeah.
And a Lord,
Lord knows that's,
uh,
that's true for anyone that has to work with them.
Like,
we're not,
like,
no one thinks that we can do certain things or,
or they're just not sure.
Like hell.
When I played hockey when I was a kid,
like the coaches on the other team would tell their players,
all right,
don't hit Brad.
We don't know what's going to happen.
Wow.
Like,
I don't know if they thought that they would hit me and I would just like
explode into candy or something like that.
But they're like,
donut,
we don't know.
He could summon a spell.
Like,
I don't know what they thought,
but uh,
yeah,
like,
uh,
like people,
people underestimate hell.
The first time I ever went on stage I got on stage because a B because I guy was
just like,
well,
you're a dwarf.
That's,
that's funny enough.
And then I went on stage and started telling jokes and he's like,
Oh shit,
you're,
you,
you actually have jokes actually prepared for this.
Yeah.
Awesome.
When did you,
what was your first time on stage telling you been doing it?
I'll be doing a 12,
12 years.
Uh,
and I've told this story on a couple of radio shows podcasts before,
but,
uh,
it,
I'll tell it just cause it's a very interesting time with you is,
uh,
I was in the audience,
have a,
uh,
Carlos been see a show and he's on stage making midget jokes.
Half the audience is laughing.
Half the audience that's sitting by me,
it's just like,
like just kind of pointing over like,
hmm.
And he notices that and you look so over and goes,
why?
Why aren't you guys laughing?
And he actually said the sentence,
what is one of them here?
And I just raised my hand.
I was like,
what's up dude?
And uh,
he,
he didn't even flinch.
He called me up on stage like,
Holy Shit,
I got to talk to you.
And I'd never done standup at that point.
And,
uh,
I walk on stage,
he started asking me questions and the answers I gave got laughs.
And uh,
that's when I was like,
Oh wow,
this is what I have to do for a living.
Wow.
So Carlos Garcia did do something good in this world.
Yay.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
That's why,
that's why I said at the very beginning,
like if you'd told me six years ago that,
that I'd be sitting with you.
I'd be like,
no way in hell.
Because there was a time,
and I talked about this with a red band on my podcast when he,
when he came on,
there was a time I hated you guys.
I absolutely hated you and I had never met you guys before,
but you know,
he was like teams,
you know what I mean?
It was like this guy's trying to take,
I'm a boss and my friend.
What's up fucker?
You know,
I get it.
He was helping you,
but you had to know.
Yeah.
It,
I mean everybody knew there's,
I mean,
but the things that he would do for me,
I can never repay the man enough cause he literally took me from being nothing
like an open miker.
Uh,
cause what?
Cause what happened was,
is I got bit by the bug.
Uh,
I started doing stand up about a year and a half later.
I showed up to one of these shows.
Um,
and he,
uh,
he recognized me and he said like,
Dude,
you're the guy to do start doing standup.
And I said,
yeah,
but doing it about a year,
he goes,
okay,
well let's,
uh,
let's get you up on stage.
Let's,
let's have you open up my show tonight.
Let's see,
let's see what you got.
And that's the whole like,
I put you up there cause you're a dwarf.
Anything that's funny.
But then Holy Shit,
you got jokes.
And when I came off stage after doing about five minutes,
he goes,
wow,
um,
do you want to be my new opening act like right then and there?
And I was,
I was a junior in college.
I was going to USC,
I had a year to go to graduate and uh,
I dropped out,
I dropped,
I dropped out to be his opening act and I was his opening act for four,
for four years.
That's first of all way better job security.
If you're funny than ever,
whatever fucking career you're going to put together.
And people tell me,
they're like,
oh,
but you were going to college.
Like,
what were you studying?
Stop.
I was a communications major,
so calm down.
I wasn't curing cancer.
Even if you were a doctor,
you know,
hard doctors have to work unless you were like obsessed with being a
neurosurgeon or something crazy like that.
Fuck that job.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm so glad that other people do it because it was so,
so dumb.
Ass is like me.
Don't have to,
well you know a guy like Carlos,
even people that do bad things,
like people that have bad ethics,
they're not always bad.
No know there's,
there's a lot of gray in this world and that's,
that's the reality of life.
And he took me on the road and when we,
and we were on the road,
he would pay for all my travel.
He would pay for all my meals.
If,
if we were ever going shopping,
he'd say,
Hey,
whatever,
you're getting thrown on my pile.
I'm good.
Like he took great care of me.
And it's funny cause I mean like I still consider him a damn good friend.
Uh,
but now I'm friends with you and like,
I'm friends with Bert Kreischer.
I'm friends with Jay more like I'm friends with all these guys like a fence
rider,
Brad Williams.
I don't pick a side.
Whatever.
That's good man.
You don't have to do to,
I have friends that hate other friends.
Sure.
I have a lot of acquaintances like that and,
and,
and if you're the can't deal with that,
their babies,
you know,
if you really need all your friends to be on your team like Nah Bro,
the fuck off.
Some people aren't going to like each other.
That's fine.
And if you have fans,
and I'm sure you have fans that will never liked me because of my association.
Not True.
I mean those,
those guys aren't really fans.
Okay.
I mean punks
and I mean that's fine.
That's okay.
If you think that that term fan is weird anyway.
Right,
right.
I hate it.
I hardly ever use it.
It just seems odd.
It seems like you're diminishing a person.
It's like people that like you,
that's what they are.
When you call someone a fan,
it's like all of a sudden like there's a,
there's like a different tier does you?
And then there's them,
there's you and then there's the fans.
It,
it's weird.
It just,
whenever you label things like that,
like there's just people,
you know,
I,
there's a lot of bands that I like.
Well I'm a fan of a lot of musicians and now I'm friends with them and it's
weird.
Why?
Yeah.
And like when I started doing comedy,
that started happening a lot.
Like I was a fan of people and then you know like once you get past a certain
level and that level is pretty much just open miker once you get past that level
you meet like every one is like if you're in New York or la,
you run into everybody.
So now I'm like,
I'm friends with David Tell,
which is weird cause I love David towl so damn funny.
And then I started talking to him and now like I get an email from them every
now and then it's like,
Holy Shit,
David tells email but I can't have that moment.
I got to go.
No,
this is your friend Dave.
This is not David.
Tell the comedy God Paul.
And we'll get those.
I still get those ones.
I talked to Anthony Bordain like,
oh,
this is my friend,
weird,
you know,
Joe Perry was on the podcast and w every now and then Joe Perry text me and I'll
show a friend.
Like,
yeah,
fucking joke again,
like Joe Perry's texting me right now
and it's been said a million times,
but I can't emphasize enough that it's true.
The people that you put on pedestals are still people.
No one is this being of all power that's hot.
Higher levels.
Like they're all people.
Everyone is a person and the most brilliant people on Earth are just people.
And one of the things that I've found is the most successful people,
the most interesting people,
people that I truly enjoy talking to their,
they don't expect anything different.
And as soon as someone does expect something different,
then they stopped being cool.
Then I like them anymore.
I can't,
I can't just talk to you.
You're,
you're now,
you're fucking weird.
Yeah.
Now,
now I have to make an appointment.
Like,
um,
uh,
I was at the Hollywood Improv and a Paul Mccartney was there.
Yeah,
I was there.
I was there that night.
He was there two different times.
Really?
Yeah.
It,
he'd loved,
I guess for a while he just loved coming to see comedy and I got to talk to him
very briefly,
but still,
but he had it like a guy that kept trying to drag him away and he kept looking
at like,
no,
no.
Sorry.
Yeah,
let me talk.
Let me tell him.
And like,
he was the guy,
whoever is fucking handler,
like handler,
whatever the fudge maggot.
Yeah.
It's just like Paul,
we gotta go,
we gotta go.
And Paul told him no,
and like took the time.
And that's literally the most famous person on the planet.
He's right up there.
He's got to be top five and he's taking time to be like,
no,
I'm going to give this guy his moment.
And I don't know if it's just because he's a great dude.
Maybe he understands that I'm Paul Mccartney and if I talked to a guy,
it's going to make his life.
Uh,
I think he's just a normal dude.
When I watched him talking to people,
he just seems like a guy who is a great artist,
but it's just a human being.
Yeah,
that's exactly what he seems like just a human being,
man.
So yeah,
it's uh,
it's cool when you realize that and it's cool when you realize,
oh yeah,
I can just talk to whoever.
And,
and when people in show business or whatever athletes that you look up to,
like I have fans that are musicians that I like and you know,
like now it's like wait,
they watch that they watch.
Yeah,
of course they watched that TV show,
they listened to that podcast.
They consume entertainment just because they're a human being.
Well that's also the cool thing about podcasts is that podcasts,
these long form long form conversations with no interruptions,
they,
they give you insight to a person that you,
you're like,
like there's a lot of people listening to this right now feel like they're
sitting in here talking to us just hanging out.
Cause that's what we're doing.
We're just,
we're just hanging out.
Yeah.
It's not that.
It's not that radio thing where it's like,
all right,
you have a fault,
you have a four minute break,
and so you got to essentially you're,
you're like pepper and you're pretty much doing your act because you're just
trying to get
as many jokes in as possible.
So people come see you and wherever a common club you're playing,
it's like,
no,
this is an actual conversation where you actually can dive into how people tick
and what people's thoughts are in the same sentence.
Four minute breaks,
they fuck with the flow.
That's why I don't break up right money ever with come with commercials.
I just do them in the beginning of the end.
I don't buy and I get all of these like really juicy offers to doom in the
middle and I'm like,
it just fucks with the flow,
man.
You can't just stop a conversation like I'll do Adam Carolla's podcast.
I love the dude.
But he'll be like,
well that's funny Shane,
that brand because a real great man.
Great man.
Great.
He'll just start talking and you're like,
oh,
you doing an ad?
Oh,
he's reading now.
Okay.
All right.
And then you sort of build up this conversation.
I think go back into it also,
one of the reasons why I like doing these really long form conversations cause I
always found when I'm talking to people,
when we're alone,
we have a,
I'm having a really cool conversation with someone.
It takes a while to sort of get cooking and then when it gets cookin everybody's
sort of relaxes and settles in,
then you really kind of understand who that person is,
right?
Yeah.
No.
Now a red band told me something when he was on the podcast,
uh,
when he was on my podcast called about last night.
What's up plug?
Uh,
that I,
that I wanted to ask you about because he said there was like a meeting at some
point.
Are you brought something up?
Uh,
during the whole feud wars thing,
call,
whatever you will where you said let's,
let's steal Mincey as midget.
No,
he's so retarded.
That's so not true.
And that was a,
that was a fucking sketch from the man show.
Oh really?
Yes.
It was a ski.
He's so confused.
Memory sucks so bad.
I was hoping there was a meeting was it was,
we definitely didn't have it.
We might have joked around about it because it was during the same sort of time
period.
But we did a,
uh,
a sketch,
Stan hope did on the man show.
He went out,
oh,
look at the devil every is came in and perfect time.
We just dissecting one of your bullshit stories.
There was a sketch for the man show where Doug Stan hope was trying to steal the
man show midget.
Yeah.
From,
from those guys.
From the guys,
the,
the um,
Adam Carolla and Jimmy Kimmel show.
And it was a,
he was a brilliant,
brilliant fucking bit.
Yeah,
it was,
yeah.
Done.
Did something to him.
Great Shit on that.
And that was one of them.
Okay.
And so mean maybe we said,
you know,
we should do that to him and see his buddy Brad,
but we definitely didn't have a fucking meeting plan out,
stealing,
haven't meeting is a meeting.
I just said it was,
you said,
you said there was a conversation where you're like,
let's do it live.
A steel mill.
We talk about,
would you blow a Unicorn if you knew you could live forever?
We've had some pretty ridiculous conversations about the answer's yes,
but yeah,
if you could live forever,
but I don't know,
man,
you might not want to live forever
more.
I as I get older,
I'm like,
who?
You know,
if you weren't alive,
you would never expect life,
right?
Because you wouldn't have any expectations.
You wouldn't be alive.
Now that you are alive where you wouldn't expect what happens after life,
we're just guessing that it's nothing.
Right.
You know,
and I'm not saying that it's a bunch of dudes in the clouds with a harp shirts.
Very possible that whatever the fuck consciousness is is not native only to this
space.
It's not.
It's not restricted only to this existence.
It's very possible that whatever you have,
whatever's going on when you dream,
whatever's going on,
when you take mushrooms with whatever's going on,
when you die,
they might be very similar things.
Your,
your,
your consciousness might be some sort of energy that moves on to some new plane
of existence that might be way cooler than this healthy body that we're all
trapped as if the,
if the theory holds true,
that there's an infinite number of universes.
Who knows that you just don't hop to another universe and say,
all right,
there's your shot again.
Go again.
Who knows?
That's not what happens every time you wake up.
It's very possible that every time you wake up you were in a different
existence.
Blow my mind already.
Joe Rogan,
I had a crazy dream about that last night.
I had a crazy dream last night.
That was a,
I had DMT trip in my dream,
which I've never had before.
Now I've had DMT,
DMT.
I'm new to all of this,
but DMT trip during your dream,
that's sort of Meta,
isn't it?
Cause isn't DMT kind of what makes you train supposedly that's a lot.
All theory,
but it's not what,
you'd never dream a DMT trip.
Like DMT trips are way more intense than a dream because you're getting,
you're flooding your brain with this chemical that's native to your brain.
But the idea being that when you're sleeping,
there's times when you're in heavy rem sleep or you're not conscious when you do
visit the same realms.
But I've never remembered it before.
Not like,
like last night,
like last night I was in there,
man.
It was really,
really,
really intense and very strange.
But it was essentially,
it was this dream was in some way telling me that this state that,
that what we're doing here right now that don't get all crazy about this,
don't get crazy about this life,
don't get too fixated on it because it's really just one piece of some sort of
infinite mandola of existence and just they're like,
that was the,
the entire DMT trip and my dream was,
was relax,
relax.
It was like somehow another coaxing or coaching rather me to,
to relax and to,
to understand that like all the stress and all the weird shit that people have
in their brain.
Like the more you can like settle that in the mall,
you can,
ah,
the more you can exist in like a real peaceful state where,
where this is like your real self [inaudible] you're just constantly being
inundated with all these different ideas and stresses and different things that
you're trying to accomplish in different things that you're concentrating on,
worrying about,
concerned about the,
you know,
that you anticipate in the future.
But I thought all these things are bullshit and that was,
that was the dream last night.
It was very,
very strange.
Huh.
Wow.
Did you,
were you on the new mood?
Was it at the five HTP and no,
no I didn't take anything.
Just went to sleep.
I mean I took some Alpha brain during the day.
Uh,
I don't know if that had anything to do with it.
I've been taking that Zma again,
I just got a new bottle of it and that,
that shit really does fuck with your dreams alive.
Cause ever since I got that bottle every night,
I haven't had dreams until I got that
zinc ups or testosterone.
It a ups,
your sperm production probably has a lot to do with the,
and then it probably helps you sleep too.
I think it relaxes you.
It helps you sleep
stuff I know nothing about.
So I'm fascinated by all by all this stuff like just in your,
cause you've done so many things in terms of other levels of consciousness and
things of that nature.
I've never even done mushrooms,
so I'm like,
I should go to shrimp fest.
You should do shrimp festival.
Ari Shaffir in the desert.
He'd do it every year.
He's been trying to get me to go.
I would love,
I would love to go like I've had.
Why didn't you go?
How come you haven't done so far?
It's such bad experiences on drugs,
but drugs just,
we'd just,
we'd,
I've had that experiences like panic attacks and anxiety attacks.
It's the good stuff.
Then you're getting good shit.
Oh,
that's this podcast.
Pretty much every couple of weeks all of us go into a panic attack.
Fantastic.
Yeah,
there was one time,
it was my birthday in Vegas and uh,
I had,
I was severely dehydrated and on top of that I took away too much of a pot
cookie and a passed out at the Rio like next to like next to a slot machine,
like just collapsed.
Like it was like a,
like a Marion editor just drop the puppet strings.
It was sounds awesome.
The weirdest thing is that like,
first,
like first of all,
it's Vegas.
So people walk by,
they see a midget passed out in the real,
they're like,
oh,
that's a new exhibit.
Oh,
that's funny.
Getting anything out of it.
Like,
did you like when you had that experience and you,
you know,
you have this panic attack after it's over.
Do you experience any,
anything positive?
Um,
I wouldn't say I like,
the only positivity I had was because I went to the hospital and they pumped me
soul full of fluids that I felt so good afterward.
I was so hydrated that that felt amazing.
So they gave you an ivy and the hospital gave me an ivy,
but you'll be so dehydrated.
I gotten a massage or early in the day and I didn't like take and it was like
the deep tissue,
stuff like that,
like really sort of like you need to drink water after that.
You need to wait a minute.
It's definitely not going to get you that the somebody rubbing on your skin,
they do into ringing you out like a dish cloth.
Exactly.
Hey Joe,
I'm very tiny.
Holds a bottle of water.
That doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
I,
I mean to be honest with you,
I don't know when they tell you after a massage drink bottled water.
Most of that's bullshit.
Really?
Yeah.
What they're trying to tell you is the get your toxins,
toxins out of your system.
I drink the water.
I know that the whole toxins,
toxic muscles are releasing toxins.
Your body is fucking processing toxins with your liver.
Right.
You know what happens when you get your,
your muscles rubbed.
It breaks up your tissue a little bit.
It's,
it's massaging soft tissue and loosens things up and it makes you feel better.
You should drink water anyway.
Sure.
No water is good for you.
But I really don't believe that,
you know,
when you get a massage,
it's releasing toxins.
I mean,
maybe I'm wrong,
but I,
I just don't see how it could have.
Some are rubbing your body can never heard a doctor say that these toxins that
are released when you have a very strenuous exercise,
like that's why those crossfit or people,
they get that rob Doe Mile Osis I think that's how you say it Rhabdo is,
um,
it's when your,
your kidneys start failing because your kidneys can't process.
Yeah.
Your,
your muscles are breaking down and the,
and your kidneys can't process all the,
uh,
the toxins and all the fluid.
It's,
yeah,
it's very dangerous.
And it's,
it was really rare up until this crossfit,
uh,
sorta craze.
But now when people go to the hospital and they,
they find that they're having kidney failure and then they have this rob doe
meiosis or however the fuck you say it.
And they always ask him,
why are you doing crossfit?
Because crossfit,
they're trying to get people to do like,
you know,
50 fucking clean and presses in a row and it,
and they'll have competitions with each other.
You're,
you're pushing your body way past,
like a workout limit.
You're pushing your pot to the point of like real failure.
Yeah.
You talked to a guy who's done crossfit for 10 years.
It doesn't have like some significant fucking injuries like significant back
injury,
significant muscle tears or something along those lines.
I'm really glad you're saying this Joe,
because now I could have a legitimate reason to not do crossfit.
Had not just that I'm a lazy fuck.
Well my good friend is Steve Maxwell,
who's is really world renowned,
uh,
strength and conditioning coach and he's worked with a lot of high level MMA
fighters.
He was one of the first Americans to get his black belt in Jujitsu and he's just
this great guy and know so much about martial arts and know so much about
strength and conditioning and health and he fucking hates it.
He thinks that what crossfit is,
he says you're doing a competition to lift weights.
He's like,
unless you're doing like a power,
like when you watch power lifting,
they did do that once.
It's like a one lift thing.
Like when you're doing a bunch of them in a row,
like what his take on it is that weightlifting should be to strengthen your body
for sports,
strengthen your body for competition and when you do a competition of weight,
weight lifting,
he's like,
it's kind of ridiculous.
It's Kinda defeats the purpose of strength and conditioning in the first place.
Like doing strength and conditioning as a sport.
He sees,
he's like,
it's kind of silly.
It's like it's supposed
to help sports.
It's not supposed to be the sport.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
The peony and there's other people that have a similar criticism and their take
on it is that when you see these big compound movements,
like,
like Olympic cleans and presses,
like these are full body movements.
Those are supposed to be done with low repetition because yeah,
well a few times maybe,
you know,
maybe a couple,
but you're not supposed to engage those muscles like that,
like over and over and over again.
To the point of failure because you're taking some big fucking risks.
You're putting really heavy weight over your head.
You're,
you know,
you're throwing your back into this it and well,
yeah,
you've seen all the youtube videos of people like dropping the weight on their
necks or like,
or like some people lose their bowels while they're doing the weightlifting and
can only be so lucky.
Yeah.
I've,
I've seen,
I've seen those videos,
so yeah,
like I,
and Shocker,
I'm not a doctor,
but that,
that that just doesn't seem right,
that it doesn't seem like your body should be doing that.
And then the other side,
a side effect of crossfit is that,
uh,
when you meet someone,
the first sentence out of your mouth is,
I do crossfit.
Yeah.
That's usually people just starting to do it,
you know,
it's like anything else.
People will just start to do it to people just become a Vegan.
You know,
when people just got into yoga,
they all do the same shit and we all just went into something that can't shut
the fuck up about it.
I've been guilty of that too.
Oh,
sure.
Vegan crossfitter.
Yeah.
It has to be the worst cross better.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
It's just one of those things where a lot of people are doing it and there are
benefits to it.
There's benefits to any kind of exercise.
You're raising your heart rate up,
you're getting your body to work,
your body's going to break down and recover.
It's going to get stronger because of that process.
There's a lot of benefits to it.
It's just I,
I'm very skeptical when I know so many people that do it and they're all fucked
up.
Like Eddie,
if is all fucked up.
His back's our wreck.
It's all and he used to totally be,
oh,
I love crossfit.
Now he's like,
fuck crossfit.
He's shit cast for that.
Right?
He's out of it now.
Like he started doing crossfit.
He has this crossfit podcast.
It has to be the most amazing podcast in the room.
Well for,
well for call for crossfitters it is because it's just an hour and a half of
talking about crossfit,
like jerking off.
Then you should work out of the day to day or do box jumps
and lifting up a trashcan with Kellen.
You know there's,
this is probably good too.
There's some good to it.
It's like everything else.
You got to know like everything in moderation,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you can run an ultra marathon if you're fucking crazy,
but you can only do them like once every few months if at all.
I have a friend and his,
um,
anything that makes it,
his ran an ultra marathon and she had kidney failure.
That was so bad.
You could take your finger and push it into her arm and it would stay like the
dent would stay and then it will like slowly come back up.
Like she was made out of remember stretch Armstrong.
Yeah.
She was like,
like human memory foams,
dehydration right from your kidney inflammation prize.
She's a damn good massage from her kidneys were failing so her body was swollen.
Like everything was all fucked up with fluids.
It's just like,
it's not good.
My friend is going through kidney failure right now.
She has,
she's just got lupus and she's getting all these infusions and stuff like that.
His kidney something that you,
you have two of them,
right?
So you can get rid of blinding and limit.
Okay.
Life at the other one are barely.
Yeah,
but it's going to be compromised.
Yeah.
They'll,
they'll probably be a moment where you might wish you had to write.
Is it,
can you think you have to be really careful about like dehydration and drinking,
drinking
hand in hand.
Our mutual friend been,
uh,
from the,
Kevin being show has one,
has one kidney.
What Ha,
what happened to him?
Uh,
he donated his kidney to a friend of his.
That's awesome.
He's a sweetie.
I love that dude.
He's a,
he's a big Seattle proponent to talk to that guy.
I love you.
Moving up to Seattle.
He almost got me that.
Fuck Dude.
I've got it up there to friends that are like that.
I have been,
and then I have my podcast partner,
um,
Adam Ray,
who's like,
who?
He's from Seattle.
I fucking love Seattle.
I just don't love cloudy weather.
That's all.
I don't love about Seattle.
I love the restaurants.
I love the people.
I think it's a smart town.
It's,
it's less materialistic.
It's less like focused on just plain looks and attention and all the bullshit
that comes with this town.
Yeah.
That you characterize for Hollywood.
Meaning we're kind of out of that loop because we're comics and you know,
we hang around with the store and it's just like we're barely in that loop,
you know?
But God damn,
every now and then I dip my toe into it.
Like I'll go to a restaurant,
I'll see Paparazzi in front and people that are like just,
just all that horse shit.
It's just so stupid.
The mind numbing.
The most annoying part about the whole la scene for me is talking to someone and
while I'm trying to make eye contact,
they are looking around for the next person to talk to.
Oh there's certain places,
if you go to certain places that's all anyone is doing is looking for famous
people to walk in and then they're going to go talk.
Like,
okay,
like I'm talking to you now because you've got,
you know,
you've done a few things in your life,
but the next person that walks in,
I guess I kind of get it because it's sort of like birdwatching like,
Ooh,
there's a blue Jay.
You know,
I mean,
well who gives a fuck of a blue?
Jay shows up.
I mean,
they're kind of pretty,
but if Jennifer Lopez walks in like,
yeah,
he has his great
45 farms to,
they're like,
oh,
there's the rare,
there's the rare Brad Williams
funny.
But,
oh look over there.
Joe Rogan,
larger large of the species.
This is weird.
So a brand used to be friends with Carlos.
What did we still friends and they'll still have this fucking,
they'll have these debates and one to ponder.
Nah,
man.
You know when I heard about,
I heard they had a falling out.
Like there's certain people that are experts on Lex celebrity relationships and
friendships.
Oh,
those people are fucking disgusting.
Those people will,
she broke up with him because she found out that he was text messaging and his
excellent.
Do you know?
You don't know.
You don't even know about your own life,
right?
You can't even fucking clean your car.
Jamie shots fire.
I wasn't talking about,
damn,
I didn't mean you Jenny the
but right after Jamie just went pale on us to see what is it at all more.
Hey,
he's a fucking,
he's an enthusiast.
I look at it like sometimes I'm mad.
I'm mad that like the tweets that I throw out there that get like the most
retweets and favorites are like Kim Kardashian jokes.
That's going to happen.
I hate,
I hate the fact that that's how it is.
Like sometimes I write like a tweet when I'm like,
oh,
this is a good one.
This is a good joke,
fun one and then see that the fucking director of x men,
he quit.
He quit Twitter because of all the mean tweets that he got.
It makes sense.
It's all from social justice warrior types.
All these people that are angry,
they're calling him a sexist and an ableist and transphobic like all this crazy
shit.
This guy is,
this guy calls himself a feminist.
I mean,
he's like a really sweet,
progressive guy and he got attacked for the way he portrayed Scarlett
Johansson's character in the movie.
It's so fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Like,
well,
it was that whole thing where,
uh,
what,
what was it,
the,
uh,
Chris Evans and uh,
they,
they got attacked because they called a fictional character.
They call it,
yeah.
They called Scarlett Johansson's character a slut.
And they're like,
that's that slut shaming.
Whew.
It's not even real.
Like,
so if I call the Easter bunny a cocksucker,
are you going to come after me and be like,
well,
that's just gay bashing God.
No,
it doesn't exist.
There was some money.
Got this one guy who's like a famous social justice war.
He's such a Twat.
And he was,
he was typing in all this shit and putting all these tweets about x men ultra
about it being violent and all these different things.
Like,
do you know what the fuck you went to see?
It's a God damn comic book Dork.
You didn't go see a,
you didn't go see Anthony Hopkins in remains of the day.
Like you're seeing a fucking x men movie.
He was comparing it to um,
it was really hilarious actually.
He was comparing it to war and like the attitudes that we have on the military,
invasion of other countries,
use of aggression like the fuck are you talking about him?
Isn't that a guy you blocked on Twitter?
And then like he talked to me.
I serious.
He blocked me.
I won't mention his name.
He's like candy man.
I won't mention his name because he's such a Dork.
He showed you Joe.
But he blocked me without me even mentioning his name.
I don't mention any of these guys' names anymore.
I like a lot of these guys.
This is why I know that their attention horse,
because all of their posts are complaining,
that's all they're doing is complaining.
You're not everyday,
not only not creating,
you're not contributing.
You are just fucking bitching all the time.
What a miserable you have to be.
We live in an amazing time.
Yeah,
but mate,
you can get video on your phone.
You go outside,
you hear birds Chirp,
you meet people,
you'll hug them.
All you're doing is complaining about a fucking cartoon movie of cartoonish
Comic Book Movie as if somehow now this is the degradation of the moral fiber of
our culture and the degrading of women.
A dehumanizing is their message behind the hulk smashing a Mercedes.
Is that that we need to not buy foreign cars?
No,
it's cause it looked fucking cool comments.
That's it.
It's constant.
The world's filled with comments someone gave me the best advice I ever got for
being in show business is Brad.
Just remember,
nobody cares about you.
That's not true.
That's advice sucks.
I said that was by shitting on you.
I love that advice and not fucking with your parents tell you that every day of
my life.
Like I love that advice.
Not for the fact that nobody cares in terms of,
no one loves you or anything like that.
But a lot of these people get in their own heads and it's very,
it's very narcissistic where it's like,
oh this person tweeted this so this offends me.
Or how does this affect me?
Or this person didn't book me on this show.
So he is mad at me.
It's like,
or there's 22 million comics in La and he didn't put on the show that week.
Come down.
Okay.
You're talking about totally different things.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're just talking about people who are just egomaniacs and completely obsessed
with themselves.
Don't be that Jamie,
can you make some team,
man,
I got some fucking crazy phlegm going on here.
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
I've got a comic friend of mine and she told me,
she's like,
I don't know.
I'm really stressing over the fact that some people said something about my
Twitter avatar picture and,
and I think it's holding you back in this business.
I'm like holding me back in the show business.
No,
you're just talking to idiots.
It's not,
no one's gonna hire you and then looks at your Twitter avatar photo and says,
oh,
can't hire that person.
There are people that do believe that those people that believe,
you know,
you have to have the perfect headshot.
You have to have this and that.
I don't even have a fucking headshot.
I need to get one.
I didn't get them together.
No,
I mean,
I kind of have a photo that I use for Twitter.
That's my profile picture on Twitter.
That's probably it.
Kind of a headshot.
But like when people say,
oh,
we need a headshot for club,
they used headshots are fucking 15 years old.
I got to get new ones.
Yeah.
Anything with hair is old San Francisco ones.
Yeah,
I,
I've been,
the clubs are like,
and then Joe Rogan's gonna come here and then they've got you with hair.
I'm like with a leather jacket.
Andre
plays to be like your news radio promo pick.
You're like,
really dude,
you couldn't find anything else while there's just so many fucking,
you know,
there's,
there's so many people out there that have ideas of like what you need to do as,
as a comic or an actor,
like what you need to do.
And it's because they're trying to figure out themselves.
So part of it they're trying to like justify their own choices with you,
you know?
Well,
you know,
I just,
I feel like this is
holding you back or I feel like this is holding me back and they're trying to
figure it out.
So they talking,
they just mom died.
I just put it out there just so hopefully they come up with the answer.
Yeah,
they're exercising their own anxiety,
man.
It's just fucking Dudee pitches.
The world's filled with nutty bitches,
bro.
That's really what's going on.
I would wholeheartedly agree.
Joe Rogan,
this poor fucking Josh Weeden guy or Joss Whedon.
How'd he say we?
How do you say that?
Who is this person?
This is the guy that directed the x man.
I read some of the tweets and holy fuck did they go after this guy?
But if that happens to me all the time and you just block it,
you don't quit Twitter,
why would you quit Twitter?
Why wouldn't you just block that shit?
Cause he's tired of assholes.
I think when it becomes part of your day to go through your Twitter and like,
okay blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Like when that becomes,
when it's adding stress that you don't have to have and just doesn't need
Twitter,
he directs movies.
He makes a ton of money.
Good for you.
Well I think that some times it's great.
I love Twitter.
I love communicating with people online.
It just,
you take a risk that you're going to run into cunts.
Yep.
And if you only run into my,
my opinion on the,
the amount of people that suck is,
it's a very small amount,
but if there are vocally active,
very small amount,
if you look at some of these people,
like we were talking about the social justice warrior guys,
that guy had fucking 15 tweets about x men and I'm not bullshitting 15 tweets
about how horrible it was.
Sexist and ablest and all this different stupid fucking shit that if you are one
person and you have all these comments on the,
the horrible nature of this one particular thing,
it's like this guy runs into that and he's,
you know,
he's fucking tired of,
he doesn't want to deal.
And there's a,
I mean it's,
it's strange because all these social media platforms,
like,
like you say,
there are unbelievable in terms of the fact that you can communicate with anyone
you could get because before you didn't know how to get an access to someone
that you were a fan of or that you watched on TV,
you would know how to do it.
Like you got to go through a publicist,
you gotta write,
you gotta write a fan club,
and then you like,
you didn't know what to do.
Now you can instantly say something to anyone and it ended,
they had a good possibility of seeing it.
That part is unbelievable,
but then you have so much else that comes with it where now because people have
that voice now,
they feel like people need to hear their voice constantly in whatever topic that
might be,
whether it be,
I got offended at this personal thing.
Everyone needs to know I was offending like that.
And we acknowledge they're there trying to get social points so when they're
complaining about something or calling something sexist or calling something
homophobic or whatever they're doing.
Sure.
Sometimes they're complaining,
but oftentimes what they're doing is they're trying to show you that they know
that something's bad,
which makes them have a high moral fiber.
They're trying to show you that they're a very moral person with really strong,
intelligent opinions and that these ass holes is it all the time and are talls
that are ruining the world.
They're below that.
I get that because I say the word midget a lot and that is apparently a horrible
word dude.
You gotta fucking green light to say midget like I got a green light to say
Guinea
and then when he gets mad at me for calling Italians guineas,
no,
my last name is Rogan.
I am mostly Italian.
So fuck you.
And if you don't think they're guineas,
you need to meet my fucking relatives.
I'll show you some pictures of some grown men with gold chains.
Okay.
Like,
yeah,
but I get attacked all the time for say for saying the word midget in my act and
it's just like,
and,
and people say like,
don't,
aren't you concerned about the message that you're sending up?
This word is okay.
I was like,
I don't,
why is it bad?
I'm still trying to figure out why people don't like that word.
Well,
I don't know.
I think it's a language police issue.
There's people that try to get rid of bossy.
Remember that?
Tried to get rid of Bossy a couple of years ago.
It gave it a hard push to and everybody went,
fuck,
fuck you.
No,
that's enough.
I think we need to do that on a lot of people complaining about sir,
about certain words that we can't say that shows you like,
why would anybody want to get rid of bossy?
Is bossy really so strong.
You know what,
and it was,
it was a sexist or something.
They were saying that they're used the word bossy to describe women,
the women that are powerful or women that are strong and in charge,
that they're bossy and that you're demeaning them and trying to marginalize them
and some sort of way.
And you know,
women were like,
get the fuck Outta here.
She's Ban Bossy with a little boy,
asserts himself.
He's called a leader.
Yet.
When a girl does it,
she's risk being branded,
bossy,
where it's like Bossy,
send a message,
don't raise your hand or speak up by middle school.
Girls are less interested in leading than boys.
Listen man,
there's,
there's a lot of that that's social and there's a lot of that that's learned
behavior and there's a lot of that that's biological and that's a fact and
that's why it's exists in almost every culture.
There's very few matriarchal cultures,
very few cultures that are run by women and that doesn't mean that women are
less than men.
That just means that you got to stop trying to make everybody even because we're
not,
even when it comes to child rearing,
we're not,
even when it comes to breastfeeding,
when not even when it comes to nurturing,
we're not,
even when it comes to emotional intelligence,
women are superior to men at a lot of ways in ended and you know,
if you try to make everybody the same,
you're going to have a fucking bullshit world that doesn't exist.
Right.
If you say like,
I think there was a story recently about a woman firefighter that got hired just
because like they needed a woman firefighter and it's like that you're going
down a slope where it's like if I'm stuck in a burning building,
like,
hey,
if she can,
if she can run up there,
granted I don't weigh a lot,
but so if she can come up there and throw me over her shoulder and get me out of
there just as fast,
fantastic,
awesome.
I want her there.
Then if you're just trying to fill a quota,
if you're like,
well,
like,
uh,
Hbo Sports,
just,
it's something where it was like,
uh,
there's not,
there's not enough blacks in baseball.
Like there's not enough black people in baseball.
We need to get more black people in baseball.
It's like,
well,
if the Dominican's can throw faster and hit harder,
that's who I want.
And baseball.
Fine.
You know what,
man,
why are you forcing it?
I don't think,
well I think there's certain issues with uh,
with sports where there is some sort of segregation or there is some sort of
discrimination and I don't know that that's one of them.
I don't know if they're trying to keep black people out of,
I bet polo now how many fucking black people playing polo?
You might want to look in a polo.
Yeah,
well cricket is a lot of,
a lot of people of color because a lot of Indians.
Yeah.
People in India love cricket man.
They would like some of the best cricket players in the world.
That was that stupid movie where they recruited a cricket players to come over
to America to pitch.
Remember that stupid movie Jon Hamm?
It's like a love story because the name is a guy and a girl and like he loves,
you know,
he,
he was struggling trying to get it together and the fucking girl and him fall in
love and the Indian guys helped him.
You know what?
I'm going to start my own campaign.
There's not enough dwarves and baseball.
There's not,
there's not,
there's not enough.
How about any sport?
Yeah,
we're not,
we're,
we're not represented.
Uh,
there's,
there's none.
There's none in the NBA.
You know,
w w w you know the fuck Joe.
What the fuck indeed.
What the fucking deal,
what's wrong with my people?
Well,
and then if you sit like when transgender people get into women's sports,
if you don't support that,
then you're a piece of shit.
Like,
okay,
you got,
yeah,
you got a lot of flack for that,
didn't you?
It was just,
just a fighter thing.
Just the one about the woman.
I'm,
I'm pretty much cool with it and almost every other way we did talk about that
woman who used to be a man.
It was six foot six and 50 years old is playing college basketball,
which I think is ridiculous.
First of all,
because she,
she essentially has given a Redo for her whole life.
She already used up or college credits.
Like,
you know,
you can only play college sports for so long,
but the,
the dig is,
or the loophole is you can only play college sports as a man.
Now when you change your name and become a woman,
now all of a sudden you get a whole new college sports career.
Yes.
So this man lived as a man,
played sports as a man,
live to be 50 got a sex change,
which I'm fully in support of.
This is what I want to say is this is super important.
I'm not in any way saying that someone shouldn't be able to do that,
but what I am saying is when it comes to athletic competition,
you've got a 50 year old man playing fucking college basketball.
Get an 18 year old girls if that's your daughter,
okay.
And your daughter,
she can't perform to the best of her abilities because it's unfair because you
have this giant fucking man,
you know who's now a woman who's 50 who's been had full testosterone for 47
fucking years or whatever the hell it is before she became a man or it became a
woman.
Like that's crazy.
Like,
yeah,
you're,
that's where sensitivity and progressiveness goes too far,
but at least then no one's getting hurt.
Right?
Where's the fight game?
Yeah,
that's it.
I had a huge fucking problem with and still do and most people do too.
And by the way,
a lot of fucking transgender people have an issue with that.
The people don't have an issue with that or,
or have an issue with me are the super progressive,
ultra liberal social justice warrior types who just don't have,
they don't have a dog in the fight.
They just not even that mad just saying they want the opportunity to call
someone a big,
they can't wait.
They just can't wait to get upset.
And just looking for the opportunity to call someone a piece of shit.
I was like,
I was,
cause there's actually a surgery that you can have to lengthen your limbs.
And I've seen that a,
oh,
it's rough.
Fuck Dude.
It's freaky likes forever.
Yeah,
it takes forever.
And uh,
and you're in pain.
It's literally they put braces on your arms and legs every day.
You turn a little crank and crank separates your bones by a mill of the,
cut your bones,
first of all your bones.
And then they put this crazy brace with these screws on it.
They did this guy in China who couldn't get a girlfriend and you know,
he changed his height from like four foot 11 until like five,
three,
but it took years,
took years and I was in agony.
Every day you're breaking your arm and leg and the bone grows and regrows
overnight.
And uh,
like we were talking about the bill burbot um,
earlier where it's like,
hey,
just wait until they get good at it.
Fucking wait until they get good at the limb lengthening surgery guys.
Holy Shit.
Cause I've seen the people,
there's no other alternatives though.
I don't like that.
I would never,
I would never get that.
I do not need to ride a roller coaster that bat.
Okay.
But let me ask you this.
If they could do it,
like say if they could do it and it was a onetime thing.
It took a year.
Like I had ACL reconstruction that took like six months and someone said,
Oh man,
I wouldn't even get the surgery.
I'm like,
but I go through the six months and then my knee works again.
Yeah.
Like if someone could do that,
if they could give you a surgery and you'd be in pain for like a year,
but after that year you would be,
you know,
five,
six,
whatever,
whatever.
See,
that's a really interesting question.
First of all,
I'd have to write a whole new act,
which is,
well,
I mean we'd write an act about how you used to be a dwarf.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Crazy operation.
And here's why.
Popping pain pills like tic tacs.
I mean if that surgery existed and it was,
I could take the pill and or or whatever and then just be five foot six the next
day and not,
cause now the guys that have that limb lengthening surgery,
they look like you've had limb lengthening surgery where yeah,
you have like,
yeah,
your mechanics are all wrong.
Right.
Your shins are longer than your upper thigh.
You know,
like,
so it just looks like you look at someone like that and you just like,
that's
he's off for,
she's off in some way.
Natural look.
Sort of like when you look at a person's body,
there's a natural distance that most,
I mean you have people that have some extra long arms are extra wide,
shoulders are extra long legs.
But generally speaking it looks fairly normal.
But then some folks they get this surgery and you're,
what they're doing is they're taking your shin bone and they're stretching that
bitch out.
So your Shin is like,
you know,
an extra couple inches longer.
Yeah.
That's not fun.
I did that.
Do anything with time too.
Right.
Did they do anything with like the snail Dick and the spikes and stuff like
that?
You guys have to wait.
Snail Dick and spikes.
So what are you talking about?
What the Flash Oh,
it was,
I mean it's just like a,
a stereotype about dwarves that that doesn't necessarily exist.
Uh,
do you have any one side stick?
I was saying that I what the fuck in the old days with spikes spikes
my cock is like a medieval weapon.
Why would you say that?
Like it's normal.
And what does it,
does that make sense to you?
Oh yeah.
Snail Dick would spikes.
You don't even qualify and it's so lazy
but uh,
to uh,
to add it,
to answer your question,
yeah,
I would probably do that.
I I'd probably cause there's health things that I'm going to go through that I'm
already going through that you're advertising people don't have to go through.
Like what kind of things you're going to?
Uh,
I've had a surgery on my legs because my legs were bowed and so I had to have
surgery on him to like straighten them up cause they were unhealthily boat.
Like I looked like I was a fucking croquet wicket and then,
uh,
um,
I have back problems now.
Like right.
Everyone has back problems it seems like,
but I've like,
cause my spine,
I've got not scoliosis,
but what is it called?
Like a gnosis where it's curved on the very bottom.
Oh,
no,
stenosis is a short,
like a shortening of the nerve canal.
It's probably something different.
I've got something where my spine curves at the bottom.
There's a lot of little people that have breathing problems.
I'm thankfully not one of those.
Uh,
but yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of dwarfs that of have back surgeries like crazy,
like neck surgeries cause and also these next are holding up these ginormous
heads that we have.
I would imagine there's a mechanical difference.
When you had the surgery for your legs,
like what do they do a,
they,
it's called,
I had what's called a dome osteotomy where they just,
they carve like a dome shape into my bone and then they just move the bone.
Like they just kind of,
you know,
and they just straighten it up.
And I had to be in a wheelchair for about like eight months.
But uh,
when did you have that done?
Junior high.
So right when you're trying to get cool,
he's in a wheelchair.
It was awesome.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
And,
and I've been lucky like,
like the fact that I've only had essentially one major dwarf related surgery,
that's pretty rare for a 31 year old little person.
Like there's a lot of us that have more surgeries that,
so
in that way,
yeah,
I would absolutely do the magical surgery that,
uh,
may doesn't exist,
doesn't exist.
Jimmy.
See if you can find that,
that piece that they did on people in China that,
that got that leg limb lengthening surgery cause it was really disturbing.
This poor guy,
they wanted to be,
he wanted his face blurred out,
but he was just talking about how he's hoping that he could get a woman,
you know,
that some day a woman would talk to them and dude,
I'm four foot four,
I get laid,
it's fine,
but you're a comic.
That's the difference,
man.
You're funny.
It does help a lot,
dude.
We've all seen some pretty ugly comics that have hot checks.
Absolutely.
Like what the fuck is this?
Why is everyone looking at me?
Yeah.
Ugly.
You're just a slob.
That's the God's thank goddess.
It.
Uh,
yeah.
So this is it,
man.
Yeah.
This is the piece could crank this up from that Geo way.
It might get us.
Have you play it like the volume?
Yeah,
just play the volume of it so we can listen to it.
Height has become a critical condition for success.
Oh Wow.
Lack the proper tallness.
You may be denied jobs.
Thomas is a word or even college admission.
Fucking sizes left out as a dating tallness isn't it?
Height one is to have their billing.
Scratch will be in Horn,
lengthy trial.
That can carry some serious risks.
Oh,
there it is.
Girls getting it done.
Weekend.
We're in depth and they're not even towards
who Dan is given a local anesthetic,
which means he will be awake for the two hour long.
Perception.
Fuck me.
No holes are drilled into.
That's a trail race.
Is this food in place?
They look medievals but they are the key to stabilizing the leg.
No one.
Goodness.
Nope,
no.
He's doing it with a wire saw.
Janet could be damage to the mirror.
Brian surrounded by this.
This is insane.
They're hammering into this guy shin.
Well,
this guy's a week will grow into the gap.
Harnessing the healing power.
This is definitely something you're going to look back and go,
that's medieval 20 years from now,
God and hear what he says here.
I don't think it's more gratifying for patients and doctors.
The the day the braces come off
after a process that has taken one long year,
that day has finally come.
Whoa.
Operation in reverse.
First the struts are removed out of their legs are here,
taking them face.
Now the patient can walk away by herself.
Now I feel more natural,
more normal,
and I feel much happier.
Oh God,
I don't see that.
I see are in how many cars ranges later.
Four inches to be joined society.
Wow.
Color and more confident.
First off,
the oranges
and your chin or your shade chooses,
that's it.
Not a foot.
His homeboy.
Yeah,
that's it.
Now when they say four inches,
it's all four inches in your shins.
Like imagine if your Shin grew that much.
I can't.
I mean,
that can't be like your Shin can't maintain the same amount of strength and
like,
well,
it definitely can.
I mean,
it's going to be exhausting.
Yeah,
it's all bone.
I don't think that's the issue.
I think the issue is like the mechanics of your body,
you're going to be different.
Especially if you do any kind of sport.
It's like you're standing on island stilts,
you know,
just just a little extra there.
Yeah.
Why don't you just get four inches put on your shoe?
You know that he wants to be naked and taller.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But like that's the part that like that whole process,
we saw a two minute clip that's a year at least.
Or like between eight to 12 like eight to 14 months of doing that for four
freaking inches.
Well maybe she could do it or upper leg and get eight inches,
maybe a freaky ass legs and then do it on your back stretch or fuck him.
Imagine eating.
You don't see your friend for like a couple of years.
Then all sudden they're six to like two used to be five,
five.
What the fuck happened?
Surgery.
Mood.
I've been doing a lot of shit like,
and,
and that's the thing that trips me out too is like these are advertised people.
They're just like five,
three,
or whatever that are getting the surgery.
When dwarves do it,
we still have the disproportionate body,
so you can still tell.
It's like,
oh,
that like you don't suddenly become like a normal looking person.
Like you look like a dwarf.
It was stretched out in a fucking taffy machine.
Like it's not like everything now fits and looks as it should.
Well,
for someone who was a dwarf,
they would literally have to stretch out almost all of your body.
Right.
It would have to be a thing where you're in constant agony arms.
Oh my God,
they've done it on this woman.
Okay.
She's got,
she's got Achondroplasia uh,
on on the left.
But then like,
look at how the thighs on the right,
like when she's had the limb lengthening your ass and thighs are still those
dwarf acid and thighs,
which are fucking huge.
They're massive.
So that,
that just,
it looks like she has a weird thyroid problem now.
Well,
it's also,
she's,
Oh yeah,
she's only lengthen to her shins,
right?
Is that what happened there?
I think so.
It looks like her upper legs and longer as well.
[inaudible] limb length and knee surgery creates controversy.
Gee,
thanks man.
Creates fucking controversy.
Okay,
here it goes.
Three foot,
10 inches tall.
Cruise associated with any challenges,
blah,
blah.
I was having hip problems,
knee problems,
back problems because of how bode my legs where that's true.
That's what you had to deal with.
This is accomplished with a series of three controversial bone lengthening
procedures using technology developed in southern California with such
procedures.
Patients,
bones in the arms and legs are surgically.
Then increased,
increasingly separated over a period of months.
The body generates new bone,
fill the gap,
thus making the bones longer.
Wow.
Does does it say what her 13 inches taller.
Oh my God.
It's pretty hundred thousand dollars four years.
Whoa.
Four years to do it.
Wow.
She became 13 inches tall.
That's incredible.
Ah,
for me that that would go to four from four foot,
four to five.
Did you be like almost my height?
Yeah.
It'd be sad.
Just shorter than me.
That's crazy.
Do it,
but you do it.
I think if I was a small person I would just stay smiling.
I think it's great.
I don't have any problem with that.
If your Dick's the same size and everything that'd be out and embrace being a
small person.
I mean I like,
I understand the things that drive these people to do it because,
and like for me,
no matter what I do in this business,
if I become a a famous actor doing movies or whatever,
standup specials,
whatever,
I'm still gonna walk down the street and kids are still going to see me and go,
mommy,
what's that mommy?
What's wrong with him?
What?
Like what?
Stop.
And so that never,
that never stops Veeresh wharf ever.
And so I,
I kind of get what drives people to do it.
They're just so depressed and so like,
cause they think that's going to stop and now their lives are just going to be
perfect but
he's going to have that.
I mean there's people that are beautiful that fuck with their face.
I mean,
yeah,
we don't have to name names,
but we know like beautiful women that have gotten their lip shot up with things
and fuck their faces up and people are crazy man.
And,
and if you start fixating on anything,
you start fixating on my shoulder should be like this.
I wish my shoulders were like this.
They need to go upper.
And you're like,
people aren't,
there was a video,
um,
that I was watching the other day about this guy in Brazil that almost had to
have his arms removed,
has been circulating cause he does this thing called Synthol.
Do you know what Synthol is?
It's um,
body builders use it to pretend that they have bigger muscles than they are.
So what they do is they inject their body with this oil and this oil makes their
muscles bulge out and this really weird,
unnatural way.
And it looks like they got like,
like,
like an infection.
It swells,
but bit by spiders.
This guy like that.
That's fuck Steven.
Yeah.
It's like he has two turtles in his shoulders.
And not only the turtles,
like not only does he look weird and crazy,
but it's totally out of proportion.
Like you look at his,
his waist and his whole thing is like,
what the fuck is that?
It's like you're sick.
It looks goofy.
Why would he think that even looks good?
Well,
why do you think women that have giant breast implants think that those things
like that got like,
ah,
I've got double D's but then I think I could go bigger.
Your lives.
A lot of women like that man.
It's like just like,
just
like certain bodybuilders.
People have body dysmorphia where they,
they look at their body and it becomes an issue.
They just can't stop fucking with their body and can't stop fucking with their,
their nose.
Like I know,
I know girl was ruined or nose man.
She had a beautiful nose.
It was just kind of a little big,
but she was pretty,
you know,
there's nothing wrong with it.
And then I saw her with ego and they don't see the pretty face and they got like
a ski slope.
There was something missing from the middle of her nose.
It's like fog.
We don't do the,
oh so crazy.
I like,
um,
I feel sorry for the people that go through it.
Like I can't imagine just nitpicking so much that well you probably have a level
of,
of body acceptance that other people don't let me know what I'm saying.
Like you have,
there's a certain amount that you just have to deal with that other people don't
have to deal with.
So when you hear people complaining about like Stupid Shit,
oh my ears are too little.
Like shut the fuck.
Yeah.
My calves.
Uh,
Mike,
Mike Calves aren't big enough.
Yeah,
look around four feet tall.
Really?
You're tell me.
Yeah.
It's like,
uh,
sometimes people come up to me after shows and,
and,
and they're like,
wow,
Brad,
what you said on stage,
I really was touched and moved by it.
Cause you know,
I go through a lot of that because I'm five foot four and I'm,
and I'm a guy and I'm like Julia lives what I would do to be five foot four,
what horrible things I would do behind a dumpster to be,
and you're out there like,
oh man,
I,
I like,
like I'm starting to accept myself.
It's five foot four because of you.
Do you pay attention to all of the scientific research that's being done and
genetic engineering and changing?
Is there anything that's on,
yeah,
like um,
they actually identified the Dwarf Jean.
Like they've been able to identify the gene that causes dwarfism and this debate
has gone on as their,
as the technology keeps getting closer to the point where we can actually do
this.
But there's debate going is if we can remove that gene,
if we can prevent your child from having tourism,
should we,
and a lot of dwarves were like,
no,
we shouldn't do it.
It's playing God.
It's stumped.
And I'm,
I'm there going,
yeah,
you should absolutely remove it.
Absolutely.
Why would you want your kid to go through?
I mean,
granted,
I've been lucky at like,
like I said,
I've only had like one surgery and I made a good career with the hand that I was
dealt.
But there's a lot of little people I know that,
that haven't,
that don't,
and then he constantly made fun of their entire lives are hidden away by their
parents.
Why would you want your kid to go through that and as a dwarf,
you know,
what struggles that you had growing up,
why would you,
why would you intentionally put those pains on your child?
I don't understand that.
I don't,
it's hard to understand a lot of decisions that people make.
A lot of rationalizations that people may like.
One reason that I'm able to be a comedian and sort of have this sense of humor
about it,
it's because my dad was amazing,
is amazing.
Uh,
like when I was born,
he found out that I was going to be a dwarf.
So he would go to these,
uh,
LPA,
little people of America meetings and he would find out about it and he was
like,
Oh shit,
my kid's going to get made fun.
Of a lot like his life is going to be weird.
So his philosophy was when I was growing up,
he would make fun of me first,
but he would do it in a supportive way.
Like he would fuck with me but didn't say,
okay,
I just insulted you,
hit me back with something,
hit me back and then get,
because this is going to happen to you later.
Bye.
It's like training you.
Yeah.
So by the time I got to kindergarten I like,
I remember kindergarten walking in in a a kid just laughing at me going,
ha ha you're little.
And I looked at him and went,
ha ha,
your mom doesn't live with your dad anymore and kindergarten,
kindergarten and fucking like I got sent to the principal's office for like,
like hurting this kid's feelings.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And like,
and they called my dad,
they're like,
we're going to call your father.
I'm like,
fucking do it.
He turned you to be a comedian.
Kind of.
Cause now like when I get a heckler,
it's like,
do you think you're going to say anything to me that I haven't heard on the
street that I haven't heard walking down and some kid haven't.
We like saying a comment like I've had,
I've had parents bring their children up to me when the line is too long at the
mall Santa and go,
hey,
tell this guy what,
what you want or you had that happen to me.
They came up,
they said,
tell this guy what you want were just a regular guy.
Yes.
Cause they're like,
well he,
well he knows Santa so you could talk to him and then he'll fuck.
Then he'll give the message to Santa.
He said them.
Um,
uh,
I tell this story in my special,
which,
hey,
I'll plug it now.
Um,
my,
uh,
one hour comedy special Brad Williams Fund size comes down and showtime May 8th,
so watch it recorded and showtimes going to replay the shit out of it so you'll
have plenty of chances to see it anyway.
Uh,
but what happened was,
is this guy came up and with his kid and was like,
you see you saw and he's working undercover for Santa.
He's going to,
it's like he's out here seeing and finding out who's naughty and nice and he's
going to go back and tell.
And like I knew in that moment where if I get pissed off now this kid who
doesn't know anything about dwarfism,
his first interaction is going to be with someone angry and that's going to be
what he thinks all dwarves are.
That's going to be the first interaction.
So I can't get pissed off.
I can't get angry because that's,
I'm setting the precedent.
So what I did was I looked at Kevin went,
you're absolutely right.
I am.
I am working undercover.
I'm going around and seeing who's naughty and nice,
but guess what?
You've been,
you've been really good.
What do you want more than anything in the world?
And kids like I want an x box.
And I looked right,
the data went,
guess what?
You're getting an x box and the dad and the dad's like,
I don't know about this.
And like,
what else do you want?
And the good that's like waving like no,
no,
no.
He's like,
he's like,
I really want to bike.
I'm like,
you're getting a bike though.
Look at getting one.
And I told the kid,
I'm like,
the only way that you don't get these things,
if your parents failed to file the proper paperwork.
So then he looks at data like,
did you file the proper paperwork down?
And it's like,
oh,
of course I did.
You son of a bitch.
Like it was so and then,
yeah.
Then the dad like gets mad at me and it's like,
what?
You brought this on yourself?
You came to get a service somewhere?
No dressed in the outfit.
Like,
all right,
if I come to the mall and I've got pointy shoes on and pointy ears,
I can't get pissed when you say,
you know,
tell him what you want for Christmas.
I can't get mad,
but that's fucked up.
You can't even wear pointy shoes.
You're into like those little Alibaba Shit,
Mexican point,
some cool shoes,
man.
Styles restricted because that seems ridiculous because it was like a fucking,
you know,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar size dude with a pointy shoes.
Knowing what to say.
Anything.
It's a genie is going to say that guy works for Santa.
Right.
That's fucked up man.
I can't wear racist at size.
I can't go through life tissues expression.
I heard,
fuck,
I forgot what show it was.
Some TV shows said it.
Oh,
I think it was the league.
I think the league on on Fx said sizes and I just heard that.
I'm like that's pretty good.
I'm gonna start using that site.
I like it.
There's a million different interests.
It's getting weird.
Well everyone has to find a way for them to be offended.
So yeah,
so you have to create what a what a what applies to you.
So now you can complain like the rest of us,
I'm hoping this is temporary.
I'm hoping this ultra complainy society,
ultra whiny stage we're going through is just a side effect of people learning
how to use the internet.
SORTA like how people didn't know how to not get crazy on in the 90s,
like in the,
in the Internet,
people didn't know how to,
you know,
people get upset at things and they overreact and freak out.
They just didn't know how to deal with people insulting them.
Um,
I'm wondering if it's because,
have we gotten to a point where like,
cause I doubt that uh,
in third world countries they're having a debate of should,
should we say bossy?
Like do you think those people who are trying to get food,
who don't have clean water,
who don't have good,
who don't have vaccinations are like,
okay,
I know all this shit's going on,
but we've got to stop saying that we're bossy.
Like we've got a focus on that.
I think it's a lack of problems and the human being is a dramatic animal.
So we create this,
we create these problems that had nowhere just so we feel like we're struggling
against something.
There's certainly a lot of that.
Certainly a lot of people that just have a too soft too.
It's too easy to get like this.
This,
the,
the ability to tweet 15 times about x men shows me that you either have no
fucking friends too much free time or your,
your career as being a cunt online.
Those things here,
you got family money or you just don't care about money and,
or you know,
you,
you don't have the real problems in their lives.
Same people.
20 years ago,
what were they picketers and how did it didn't exist?
It's too hard picketing.
You have to actually do something.
You have to show set up.
You have to love people in the eye.
If you're standing out inside of an abortion clinic or you're,
you're picketing in front of a warehouse,
it's nonunion and you got to make fucking contact with people.
You got to get her act organize.
You have to be good at arts and crafts.
So you have a sign that's like halfway decent.
All you have to do when you want online.
It's just fine.
Other cunts and you know,
you gravitate through forums or you know,
Twitter groups and you just can't it up together.
You know,
that's what you're getting a lot.
Cut it up together.
Joe Rogan,
he create this negative ripple for no reason.
Really.
You just know you can enjoy a movie or not enjoy a movie.
You can write a review about a movie,
but this idea that you,
you know,
if I go see a movie that sucks that I did not like,
I'll walk out of there going,
well I didn't like that movie.
If I could,
we had a restaurant that shitty.
I'm just going to say,
well,
I'm not going back to that restaurant.
I'm not going to go online and start this campaign of everyone must think like
me.
Everyone was not go to this restaurant.
Everyone got a Nazi this movie.
Fuck you.
If you like Paul Blart mall cop too.
Hey,
if you like Paul Blart Mall Cop,
Dude,
more power to you.
It does not affect me.
You enjoying that movie does not have any repercussions on my life at all.
So I don't care.
Like whatever movie you want to watch,
you,
you like enjoy whatever comic.
Like in terms of the feud that you had with ned.
Some people are like,
you have to be either a Joe Rogan fan of work.
Carlos been CFN.
You gotta be a fan of both.
You can be a fan of no,
Larry the cable guy.
That's where I draw a line that you're talking crazy side.
You're talking nonsense.
You can be a fan of Larry the cable guy and bill Belper.
Yeah,
but they don't hate each other.
Okay.
Right.
Different.
I get that.
Is it different than apparently I was saying x amount earlier.
It's a vendors that say x man,
Xanax one.
Oh,
are you getting those all the same shit to me comics and give a fuck.
But it's just like,
like people who enjoy a certain music.
Like if you like,
if you enjoy the band
name your band that is supposedly shitty it sure of kiss done.
I've had people get angry at me because I love kiss fuck off sue and the pixies
can suck it and you're such a simple band.
They can't place pyrotechnics and facial makeup
musicians.
It's like,
or I can listen to their music and it makes me happy.
Or you're moody and you're just a moody bitch and you need people to cry and
their songs.
Hey,
guess what?
Sometimes I like listening to Motorhead.
Sometimes I like listening to
Sadik.
Sometimes I like listening to her.
I think you'd have to say it different than that.
Yeah.
Shaq Smith.
Sometimes I like that.
Sometimes I want to rock and roll all night and party every day.
How about fuck when?
When?
Whenever I accomplish anything halfway decent in my career,
and this is absolutely true.
I go into my car,
I played Katy Perry's firework.
I rolled down the window and I lip sing the shit out of that song.
I'm like,
he was running.
I go nuts with that song.
Isn't it funny though with people that people actually do do that?
They don't like people for their choices?
Like,
Oh,
you fucking listen to that.
Like there was a guy that had a fucking bit about that way back in Boston.
Oh,
it was Barry Crimmins.
Barry Crimmins a hilarious comedian who bobcat Goldthwait has a documentary that
he did about them cause apparently Barry was like molested when he was younger.
He's got a documentary called call me lucky or they call me lucky.
It's supposed to be like really dark and really good.
You know,
bobcat is awesome.
I'm Rachel maker,
but um,
anyway,
um,
he had a bit about going to the record store and the clerk at the record store
like you listening to this and those guys.
Fuck you man.
It brings me joy.
That doesn't affect you in any way whatsoever.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
That's it.
That's Barry Crimmins and I dunno,
what are they doing with their pose there?
Don't know.
I don't know.
Look,
it looks like they're trying to look like dwarves Bob.
Let's say this.
Oh,
good gorillas.
Gorillas are standing up in their back things.
Yeah.
Barry Crimmins was like,
back when I was starting out,
I was an open miker he was already established comedian.
He was like one of these,
you start in Boston too.
Yeah.
He was one of the,
like the main guard of the established comedians in Boston,
like to establish headliners,
like really,
really respected guy.
Very original political,
very political,
just very just very wise guy.
That's a really good things to say.
He's really good to follow on Twitter too.
His Twitter is filled with a very good points and also he,
he'll tweet some great articles and stuff and different things.
But a bobcat also started out in Boston.
So bomb.
He uh,
he did this documentary on Barry and I don't think it comes out for a couple
months,
but I think right now they're touring and doing the,
um,
you know,
the festival thing,
trying to get it up there.
Fantastic man.
I'll put that fucking thing down in.
Contribute to be a part of the show.
The periscope,
periscope.
Uh,
no.
Do you like consume all like movies or whatever that's standup related?
Like can you watch like the new Kevin Pollak one?
What's new Kevin Pollak?
One something wrong.
People be a miserable misery.
Loves comedy,
loves misery or something like that and see that I've got that queued up ready
to go when I get home.
So I was like,
I like,
I love all those types of movies.
I like some of them,
but we're around comedy all the time.
I don't need someone to tell me what comedy is and I don't need someone just
like the idea that I'll do comedians have to be miserable.
Let's this.
Like I have friends and aren't miserable in the comedians.
I don't have to explore that.
I mean,
yeah cause you cause you know,
or it's like,
or it's like you could just sit back and enjoy their art and say like,
okay,
yeah.
Like do you have,
do you have to go into the mental state of a Jackson Pollock or can you just sit
back and be like,
wow,
there's some cool paintings?
Yeah.
Well like,
um,
well,
I mean I don't think there's a problem with exploring whether or not comedians
are miserable.
It just,
I don't want to do it.
I don't need to do it.
I don't like that idea either.
That you could just want everybody together like are all musicians dickheads,
right?
Right.
Musicians are dickheads.
Sure.
Who was the thing you sent me the other day?
Stone temple pilots guide.
Oh my God.
Scott Wieland wasted on something or,
but he,
that was sad to watch.
He,
he's not in the band anymore.
Right.
They kicked him and kicked him out.
Now the lead in Lincoln Park is touring with them.
Wasn't that the same Banjo that you saw at a private party?
UFC party or this is Dana White's birthday party.
His 40th birthday I think it was and God damn it dude.
They fucking nailed it.
They did that show at a private party.
There was only a few hundred people there and they did that show as if it was a
packed arena.
I loved it.
I mean he did.
He had is the Bull Horn,
you know,
he does like some of his songs.
He sing some of it like the change,
the sound of his voice.
He sings into a bull.
It was us,
Scott Scott Weiland.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
STP.
Let me hear this.
He just had the party.
Oh,
I can tell you right now that guy,
he can't even balance correctly.
That dude is something,
he's on some hair.
All as Joe Diaz would say dancing.
He's moving in slow motion.
Yeah,
I bet he's having a good time though.
Sure.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He's tripping.
Let me hear this.
It's one,
it's one node.
He's just,
he's,
he's heron.
Dabbing my eyes.
Dead Eyes.
It
was the total opposite of this.
You saw like jumping around.
It's moving.
Yeah.
I mean he was crushing it.
I was really,
really,
you know,
I have no musical talent at all,
so I love watching musicians because you've watched musicians,
you can kind of get this inspiration from them that's totally unrelated to what
you do.
And like I was really impressed with him as a performer just as just as an
artist.
I was like,
this guy's fucking bringing in because he's showing up to some,
yeah.
Was showing up to some private party.
They probably got all fucking ass load of money she had.
Apparently he was a nightmare to deal with backstage.
They were threatening to walk if the show didn't start right now.
Like it was all this craziness to it.
Like it wasn't chill about the experience at all.
But yeah,
the one,
but you know,
maybe he's amped up to get up there because once you got up there,
he was fucking smashing it.
It was sorry it was so tight.
Spoons and like everything he was doing was such like energetic and focused and
I was super,
super,
super impressed.
It's cool and you can see someone who's really in their element,
you're like,
oh yeah,
you were absolutely put on this planet to be a rock star.
Like this is what you do and you're fantastic.
I would never say that,
but I would say he's nailing it.
Yeah,
he's whatever it is that takes to be a rock star,
that guy is in that groove.
He's in that headspace.
He's worked really hard.
He's done all the preparation necessary and he's producing it in a very,
very high level that that's,
that's one thing I definitely would say.
I don't think anybody's born to be a rock star or born to be a poet or any of
that.
There's a lot of silliness when it comes to that kind of shit.
I think some people's personalities because of whatever reason are better suited
for certain activities.
But that makes sense.
I don't think anybody's born to do anything,
you know,
they just,
they just kind of discover where they kind of,
where their talent or where their personality can sort of fit the best and then
they just,
yeah,
accelerate.
I mean,
find what you enjoy and do it.
I mean like for you,
like,
you know,
you're in college,
men see it brings you on stage.
You,
you,
you say funny shit and you realize I can be funny.
Holy Fuck.
Like the next thing you know,
I mean,
what was that process like?
Did you get home and start writing?
Did you start watching comedy?
Like what did you do?
Consumed everything.
One moment.
One Blip.
Just cause I got a laugh and it was,
it was a sold out.
It was a sold out improv and I was just like,
wow,
this is in,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the drug of standup of being on stage and sang something and then having a whole
room,
a stranger is just laugh.
And it was,
and that,
and for me,
I've always used laughter is like kind of a defense mechanism because when I,
when I meet people,
I try to immediately make a dwarf joke just so they're comfortable just so they
like go like,
oh,
okay,
he's cool with it.
And then I can kind of,
and now and now we can be friends.
Like now we can move on past that.
Uh,
so that's like something you learned over the years.
It has to do with the way your dad sort of like,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Because,
and you know,
cause then if I don't talk about it,
then people are like on pins and needles because they don't know if they're
going to offend me or if they're going to like say something that's going to set
me off,
you know,
so there,
so if I make that quick joke,
then they're like,
oh,
okay,
you're fine.
Um,
I don't have to worry about it.
Uh,
so yeah,
as soon as I went on stage,
the first time I went home and I just started writing like crazy and just
started writing all the stories that I've told it parties for years,
just of experiences and,
and things like that.
And you started watching a ton of comedy.
Someone showed me that Jerry Seinfeld documentary,
a comedian,
and I was like,
I was an man.
That's a sneaky documentary.
You know why?
Because he put [inaudible] Adams in that movie to make himself look good.
I know he did.
I know he put already like already,
like he,
they focused on like what?
They come to you and they say,
look,
you're going to be at a documentary about comedy with Jerry Seinfeld.
Like,
fuck yeah man,
you're a struggling comic.
And they narrow in on this neurotic guy.
It was a mess.
And he's freaking out and he's trying to get,
and they just,
he's got no experience being on camera and you just fucking shove this Cameron
and then contrast it.
Makes Jerry Seinfeld look very,
very likely.
He's polished and he's done this for years and now he's trying to do the new
act.
And I'm like,
Eh.
But then at the same time like,
and then as comics,
we know this now,
like yeah,
Jerry Seinfeld was trying to write new material,
but w w and when he's going on stage,
like he's done this a thousand times.
So that scene where he's essentially trying to think of a word or a bombing as
some people would say,
he's very comfortable in that scenario because he knows what to do.
And he's very analytical cause he's done it a million times.
It's not already to wear when he goes on,
he's,
you know,
he's neurotic and he's learning all this stuff because yeah,
I saw that movie.
I thought I,
I thought I knew Warren,
he Adams.
And then I actually met the guy,
I'm like,
oh,
you're fucking cool.
It's just a normal dude.
But you know,
they edit it,
they focus on all the most ridiculous shit does get their cameras phase.
You have Barry Katz breaking you down on camera,
which is a posture as the whole thing.
I saw that,
I'm like,
they set this dude up like they used him and his fucking documentary.
But you know,
if you really going to show a guy creating a new material or guy,
you got to kind of do a guy who is not loved already.
Right.
You know,
you can't walk on stage and get a standing ovation before you've said one word.
So that's where [inaudible] comes in.
Right.
So it's,
I think they kinda,
it helps to have a guy like that we can follow following another guy,
but on the way up,
why did they choose or [inaudible],
you know,
choose the guy who's not going to overshadow him.
You know,
it's interesting like,
you know,
they didn't do like a Kevin Hart type character or some big powerful energetic
performer would just crushes and like,
well hell,
they have all this.
They had the one scene at a Caroline's where,
I don't know who the comic was.
It might've been an angel.
Cells are,
but it got out.
Yeah.
Chicago chicken out.
We're like,
he was doing his costume changes on stage at,
yeah,
I think it was Caroline's.
And then you see Jerry in the back like,
well,
how am I going to follow this?
They got how many people want after this?
Be Fun.
Yeah.
Just walk on stage and say,
hi,
I'm Jerry Seinfeld.
Didn't tell a couple of jokes.
Boom.
You following it until jokes that are actually good.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Don't worry about it,
dude.
That's it.
But yeah.
Yeah.
I just,
I just consumed all things comedy.
I never saw that I am comic either.
It was just,
that was the documentary that everybody always quotes because that's the one
where I'm in.
He admits the steel in material and he does that.
That interview was talking about.
Yeah,
I steal.
Of course I steal.
You know,
if I'm on stage you better run bitch.
I was sarcastic.
I think it was doing to be sarcastic.
Can't do that if you actually are.
Yeah,
that's how do you do that if you actually are a plagiarist.
I mean that's,
that's preposterous.
But that's how,
that's all I know about that documentary.
Oh yeah.
Cause I'm sure people tweeted you that clip like that.
See is that a touchy subject with you and talk about your friend?
Yeah,
kind of.
Cause it's like guy,
he's my friend,
you know,
and,
and we're still friends and so we still text every now and then.
Hell.
So some of your fans will probably like when that thing was at its peak,
uh,
there was a moment where some,
your fans will probably hate me for this,
but he called me up and was like,
I'm quitting.
I'm not doing this anymore.
I'm not doing standup anymore.
I'm not,
I'm out.
I'm just,
this is too much.
I can't.
And I like,
I was on the phone with them for like three hours and like talk him in the back
into doing it.
Yeah,
I know.
See Yeah.
Nothing wrong with him doing stand up.
Cause you know that's not,
there was never the issue.
What the issue always was was he was victimizing other comedians and you might
not known it because you weren't around.
I went around the scene,
I like,
I like mystery and,
and this,
and the sad part is is cause because I was with him on the road,
I would see things happen during the day and then him go on stage that night,
do 20 minutes on what happened during the day and have it be brilliant stuff.
I'll be the first one to say he's a great comic when he's like being a comedian,
you know what the problem is?
People get addicted to killing and they want to kill all the time.
And when they don't have something to say,
they'll take somebody else's shit.
And that's the reality of it.
It's a lack of artistic integrity.
And that's the reality.
It doesn't mean you're not talented.
It's like we were talking about before,
there's grays,
there's not everybody's good,
everybody's bad or you know,
everybody on this side is good everybody and that's how it's bad.
It's not that some people are really talented,
but they're,
they also have questionable ethics and that's,
that's reality.
And because what is most important to them is adulation and love.
It's filling up that hole.
Whatever that hold it was created.
We all have a whole,
every comic has a hole that was created by their childhood.
Some more than others.
Sure.
No,
some,
some in a different way than others.
Everybody's,
everybody's varies.
And some people that the need to kill is way more important than the need to be
original and the need to be creative.
And when they don't have anything to say,
when they don't,
they can't.
They can't find something.
They'll just steal.
And once they steal,
they steal all the time and one state that becomes what they do then.
And they do it to their friends.
They do it to people they don't know.
They do it to open Miker as they sit in the back room and they write things down
and he's not the only one that's ever done this.
He was the only one that was ever called out for it and got busted for it.
Public and publicly.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
and these things still happen today where,
you know,
behind the scenes someone comes up Sean and says,
hey look,
there's,
it's still an issue.
Like artistic integrity is always going to be an issue.
There's for sure parallel thinking
for sure.
There's,
there's going to be people that come up with similar jokes.
Like there's always something that happens in the news,
like Kanye West interrupting Taylor Swift's is going to be a bunch of people
that have a joke about that.
I see with Twitter you'll see it because I met when,
um,
I remember when Bruce Jenner,
uh,
gotten to that car accident and,
and the,
and the woman died.
One of the first tweets I saw was Neal Brennan saying,
great.
Now every comics going to say that,
uh,
Bruce Jenner's really becoming a woman because he can't drive.
And that like that was his tweet and then sure enough,
within minutes you saw Comedians tweet that joke like sure.
It just filled up the line because that's the most obvious punchline there.
Right?
Like you have all these eyes looking to one topic.
Yeah.
That's what they're going to come up with.
It was pretty fucked up that they,
did they even bring that up in the two hours that no.
Oh,
by the way,
by not paying attention.
Right.
Yeah,
and it was taught,
I mean anybody else in that similar situation like that would be the main focal
point.
Oh by the way,
you fucking weren't paying attention while you were driving giant truck with a
fucking boat behind it,
which I used to mashed.
What do you mean?
I think on the PCAS that somebody said that you're not supposed to have trailers
or something on that street because of that reason.
I've stopped being fast Google that.
Find out if that's true,
but I don't know if that's true.
Could be true.
You could have done the Diane Sawyer interview on the fact that you fucking
killed someone a month ago.
A month ago.
Yeah.
Glossed over it like it was,
that's not important.
What's important is a woman are you a woman and kills people by negligence,
by pure negligence while you're smoking his cigarette.
And I think I heard,
um,
I heard a her Corolla talk about this and I thought it was really interesting.
I mean,
the fact that like I think the car he hit and then she veered off into oncoming
traffic and the car that hit her,
it was like a homer and that,
that part sucks cause you're like,
well,
if you get hit by a yard,
good.
Ars Ars is a,
I don't know,
it's a little,
little tiny car.
It's not that,
yeah,
it doesn't matter.
But like,
yeah,
you get hit by any sort of regular to pull up a yard.
It's fine.
It's a,
it taped the interview before the car accident it says,
oh,
well there you go.
There you go.
Oh,
so okay.
okay.
Yeah,
there it is.
I mean that makes them kind of like an asterisk tapered so long ago.
Yeah.
And then not,
and then just sit on it.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
But yeah,
it gives a fuck really.
But it was the whole thing of where like out of all the cars on the road that
hit you head on,
it had to be a hummer and that's not good.
No,
it's just negligence like that.
It's just so infuriating and to have it,
you know,
from a person that's in the public guy,
people get really angry about it.
But in this set,
in this case it seems to be
like fading.
Like no one really seems to give a shit about it other than the people that
directly knew and they're like,
there's people that are trying to sue,
but then the stepdaughters and apparently they didn't even have a relationship
with a woman and they're suing.
They're like,
oh,
but you took away their,
my chance to rekindle that relationship so I deserve $1 million.
It was kind of the true God who the fuck is to say that I was going to call her
tomorrow.
If there's anybody that deserves like money from like a lawsuit.
It's not the people suing Manny Pacquiao for 5 million bucks cause he had a hurt
shoulder.
It's the people who,
well,
Hey,
Bruce Jenner killed my mom.
Okay,
okay,
sorry,
I got some money.
He's,
it's not only these broke.
Let's keep that.
Let's give you some money for that.
It's a,
and you almost never hear about that anymore.
You don't hear about the fact that he,
it's all hear about it at all.
No,
it's just in becoming a woman now fades away.
It fades away into oblivion.
It's interesting how the public decides to fixate on certain things and not fix
it on other things.
Like I was thinking about that when it came to this police violence case,
you know,
the public will decide which one to Freddie gray one.
There's one that sticks,
but this South Carolina one where the cops shot the guy in the back on video
just wanting away.
The guy was running away.
Yeah.
It wasn't a guy who died in the back of a van.
It was a guy who's running away and the cop shoots.
I'm like,
come on.
That one didn't stick.
I am shocked.
Well,
it's like a,
it was kind of like a few years ago and all these,
a bunch of comics made jokes about it,
but it was like whenever he,
when it was like missing kid time,
it was like we're this,
every story is going to be a new missing kid.
And everyone made the joke that was all like good looking white women and not
just girls.
There's so many other missing kids and now it's Kinda like that.
But with police brutality,
like it's almost like the news just sits down one day and says,
why are we going to focus on this week?
Like,
like,
like what's going to happen?
Did you see nightcrawler?
Yes.
That's a perfect,
perfect movie.
If you want to understand like this whole,
like this leads,
it leads style of news.
Well it also gives you really a real insight into what,
what a new show is.
It's an entertainment program.
They're trying to get ratings.
Same way everyone else is you.
They're not trying to enlighten you,
they're not trying to educate you.
They are just trying to somehow or another get you to pay attention.
That's why I like a,
the,
the speech and the TV show,
the newsroom.
Uh,
it was near the beginning of the first season,
uh,
Jeff Daniels plays the news broadcaster and he talks about what the news was
designed to be and how there were people that when the news was first conceived,
they,
they said,
no ads,
no sponsors,
government funded or I mean,
how then you go and do a whole nother part where they can't talk about different
people.
But yeah,
it's like a no sponsors to where they have to get ratings just right.
This is the news.
It's going to be put on by taxpayer money.
You pay a little extra,
get you get the news.
So now it's not people with the,
uh,
the news ticker at the bottom,
trying to sensationalize everything.
What did Hillary Clinton really mean when she said Bubba,
Bubba,
Mclaren's are Democrats and they're fighting and like,
so the news casters don't have that to go to.
And I thought that was a great little monologue that made,
that made me kind of think like,
yeah,
why do we,
like why is the news have to be ratings?
Cause and it's like you said,
it's an entertainment show and it's all it is.
At the end of the day,
the traffic,
they're trying to get eyes to try there,
try and get sponsors.
They're trying to get,
they're trying to get ratings.
So yeah,
you're going to lead with uh,
you know,
does sensationalized murders and the a,
that's how you get people to pay attention.
It's the only way.
It's also like what we were talking about earlier.
It's like when you run into like most people that you communicate with online,
like my,
my interactions with people on Twitter and on Instagram or Facebook are almost
universally positive.
There's very few negative people,
but I've run into,
and most of his,
because I'm nice and I don't cause too much bullshit,
but I say controversial shit.
She just,
I run into enough nice people,
but there's a certain percentage that are just,
and it's just a numbers game.
Well when you,
when you're dealing with the news,
if you try to put on an hour show and you're dealing with the events of 7
billion people and the Nepal earthquake and the typhoon that hit the
Philippines,
this and the that and the that and the this and the murder and the dads and the
cop and the shot and the boy and the baby and the window,
and you can just fill that hour up with these events because the sheer numbers,
if you just looked out,
if you opened up your window and you looked at your apartment and you saw 7
billion people,
you'd be like,
well,
of course some shit's going down.
There's too many people.
It's going to happen.
And the events that you're dealing with,
if you're dealing with even like one 100th of 1% of chaos and violence,
sure.
That's pretty good.
When you consider what the world must have been like,
you know,
five,
6,000 years ago,
people just fucking show up and you cut your village in half with swords and
then just say,
all right,
we own it now.
Yeah.
Flaming Arrows to go flying into the algorithm and doing this again.
You know,
that was the news.
I mean,
that was what the news was back then.
The news was you open up your window and people are trying to kill you here.
Here's who your king is now.
All right,
great.
So if you try to like pack a 7 billion person,
like a report on the events of 7 billion people,
how the fuck are you going to do that in an hour?
You're not and you're not getting an hour by the way,
you get 44 minutes,
the commercial,
the minutes or 16 minutes commercials and they're like,
the news is biased and you're like,
well yeah,
for that reason,
because they have to look at all events and say,
which ones do we want to focus on?
Well,
data there,
their job is not to educate,
you know,
their job is to get you to pay attention.
That's it.
And we have this idea that somehow or another they're like our educators,
not like this is the news.
And you know when you hear them talking in that strange way that news casters
talk calm Brokaw voice.
Yeah.
It's my favorite is when they uncomfortably tried to comment on things in
between storage.
Well that's upsetting,
but it certainly is
next door.
Yeah,
the local news broadcast like after the last story and that 20 seconds at the
end of the broadcast where they have to like be funny or just interact.
Did you see that one where
the a woman was talking to a black guy?
There was a woman who was a white,
a newscaster and she had a black eye with her and they were talking about lady
Gaga.
Lady Gaga did a performance and she starts calling it Jigaboo Mu Music to see
she doesn't know what Jigaboo is apparently.
Have you seen that?
Listen to this
course.
It's Fox News
and called it listen,
this.
Oh my God.
How about the black?
I just saw I going,
yup.
Wire right there.
I have a mortgage or a robot.
Has there been anything like that though that you've said that you didn't know?
I didn't know it was racist to say,
hey boy to a black guy.
Like I remember saying it moved to La and I remember the first year I was out
there,
you never say hey boy to a white guy.
Yeah.
Well I mean it was like,
what's up boy?
Until like I remember said that to my friend and my friend goes,
what?
What?
Wait,
what you just saying?
It was like,
boy,
Guy,
hey man.
He goes,
do you know what?
You shouldn't say boy to a black a hit.
And then he explained to me like,
I've never heard this before in my life.
Well now we're going through that with a trainee.
Like you can't,
like you can still say cabbie though for cab drivers.
So cling to that.
They won't,
they won't even exist in another few years after Uber.
Like did I tell you I took a cab the other day,
I did not know how much more expensive it was and how bitter they have.
Like the second I got in there,
that's all they talked about was how horrible Uber was.
Uber.
No,
I had no,
I didn't say.
And I was like,
oh thanks man.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
my phone's dead so I couldn't call Uber so I couldn't so I couldn't call because
I was,
I had to flag down a taxi and uh,
it has like my phones,
I couldn't call a and he goes,
oh that's the word Uber.
And the whole time,
the whole ride home,
he was just bitching about Uber.
Sure.
Cause they had a monopoly in the market.
Then someone figured out how to do it better.
And you ran into a cunt and it was $20 more like it costs are the same run.
Yeah.
For the exact same.
Right.
I've taken a million times with Uber,
20 hours more.
How do the,
how do they get paid?
They get a check from Uber.
Is that how that works?
Yeah,
I think it's twice a month.
It's direct deposited into their,
you do any background checks on the people that are involved?
Yes.
Boasts two.
And now with all the latest news and stuff,
it's gotten more intense.
But uh,
it's still,
it's still easy.
I mean,
I know a ton of people who are comics that are Uber drivers and I was like,
what?
You're driver?
Well David Seaman was a,
uh,
heard about that.
He does some fucking Uber driving in his spare time.
That's just the pickup chicks.
I remember when dead mouse was doing it.
He was,
we were driving up in Toronto and they had his logo.
Like you don't have to hit the car logo.
Like he was the 10 house mask and yeah,
that was odd that that was on the map.
Like that must be cool as fuck dead mouse and trip driven around in a Ferrari.
What if you have luggage though?
You can have a trunk.
You fuck.
Yeah.
Like could you imagine just being on the side of the street,
be like,
I call this Uber then like Gene Simmons pulls up.
Joe Rogan were very rich and powerful man.
And then to get back to their super lucky to get someone who's not totally
retarded in your car though.
Yeah.
Well now like a,
there's thing like,
um,
Hillary like Hillary Duff is getting a lot of press cause she's on Tinder.
She's like filming it and stuff and like cute,
like she's trying to do a reality show.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
Jamie knows he's just nodding his head over there cause that what she's doing.
Let's go to our US weekly report with Jamie watching.
Say that again for you did a few dates and they filmed a couple things and they
went on.
Well she probably film it just so nobody kills her,
right?
Yeah,
no shit.
Some psycho shows up and it's Hilary duff.
Speaking of Psychos,
I watched going clear last night.
Oh you haven't seen that before?
Oh my God.
I read part of the book soon.
Like some clips from the documentary,
but oh my God,
I watched it last night.
That is incredible.
You know Scientology is down to only 50,000 members.
That's what they were saying.
And with that they still have whatever dollars they have over a billion dollars
in care.
I mean there was a equity there.
There was like two sponsored tweets today that I saw like by ontology,
Scientology,
they and what's their Twitter handle?
I think it's just that Scientology or at Church of Scientology or at we will
control you.
You small weak minded amp or something.
Something like that.
Uh,
and uh,
Scientology.
Yeah.
How many people that have?
28,000.
Damn,
that's it.
That's it.
I have more followers.
A Scientology route.
28,000.
But like,
look what their top photo is like.
Their top photo of the Church of Scientology is a lobby of a hotel or building
that looks like a palace.
Like that's what their logo is.
Well that's the church.
That's where they party.
They give praise to Xenu.
Yeah.
Neat.
Heikki a mother and scientologist.
Oh Wow.
So I guess they're like on a publicity run to try to be the same way.
A seaworld now,
how that has those commercial,
yet we love our way.
Look at this because of Scientology.
May Yuku treats her young son as an individual.
As a result,
he's a happier child.
Why?
As opposed to what you treat him like he's a fucking puzzle piece.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
What parent isn't doing that and it's because they're not a scientologist is
weird.
Weird.
Joe,
did you see the the the sea road,
like how that new commercial that they've been playing since like we haven't
captured a Orca in the wild for 20 years or something like this,
forced them to breed in captivity as slaves.
All cities going on.
I mean we're just confirming.
This is really wild man.
They're trying to go for it to the diversity angle,
the Scientology,
a Twitter page,
the Scientology mission of Katmandu serves as the base camp for Scientology,
Nepal Disaster Response Hashtag Nepal quake.
We're helping.
Wow.
I don't know.
I'm sure that'll help by completely obliterated psychiatry and the in the Nepal
region and then all the people will be better.
It's just amazing when you see the actual films of l Ron Hubbard talking.
Yes.
You know,
that was what it was amazing.
And Paul Haggis,
the director like who like got to like some super high level.
You get the handwritten notes from l Ron Hubbard.
He was like,
what the fuck is this?
Did you see it?
Have you seen the document?
You have to because you have to whole new level.
That good.
It's that good.
I,
I got it last night on HBO go.
You ever use HBO go?
I just got it last night to go watch the nirvana movies on there now.
Yeah,
go band thing.
Yeah.
I was going to watch that too,
but I said,
no,
I'm going to watch this.
I really,
it was late at night and I was like,
I'm just going to watch this for like 10 15 minutes.
Nope.
I was going to Lou to that motherfucker for two whole hours.
It's sad to men,
some of the people's bad experiences with their children or with their family.
It's being taken away and being forced to work on top of the roof of a building.
Fuck Dude.
It was how the mother whose daughter won't talk to her anymore and the whole
family grew up Scientologists and it's really hard to watch.
And then the guy who started taping,
the people that were out in front of his house,
like the Scientologists out front of his house to do a smear campaign against
them.
I think it's really important whenever you're talking about something like this
to look at both sides of it and just does not look at both sides.
This is only one side of it.
I had a neighbor that was a Scientology,
actually I don't think he is anymore and I don't live near him anymore,
but he was a scientologist.
He was the nicest fucking guy and he was telling me how much it helped them,
how much it,
it got his life in order.
So I don't think it's all negative.
I think there's,
there's some horror fucking stories.
Well sure.
It's the same thing like uh,
like some of the nicest people I've ever known in my life were Mormons.
Mormons are great.
Fantastic.
Her religion I would,
I really would pick more minutes.
I really,
I mean
they're all family oriented.
They all like kept like tight knit or they try to have tight knit families.
They really like supportive.
Their church functions are pretty pretty and they'll and they all kind of band
together to help each other.
I mean,
granted then you have the instances were polygamists and girls are being married
off at age 12 and like some sort of weird sex though.
Mormonism,
they don't really have those though.
You know?
That's,
you know,
that's Mitt Romney.
Do you know how the whole deal with Mitt Romney?
Oh No.
Oh this is great.
Oh,
this is my dad's like a hardcore Republicans and Mitt Romney's dad couldn't be
president because he was born in Mexico.
The reason why I was born in Mexico was because Mitt Romney's family is from an
extreme sect of,
of Mormonism.
Then left the country when polygamy became illegal.
So it left the country in the 18 hundreds back when there was no cars when they
were,
there was no cars.
Mexico is just as cool as America.
It was probably even cooler.
So it,
let's just go over there.
Fuck it.
We're on.
Horses would write one on differences.
May cause this land in the land.
Yeah,
you have a horse over here.
You have almost over there.
Have a worse over here.
You could have 15 wives,
you know,
lock them up in a dungeon.
You have a party,
you know,
over here you have to have one wife and they tell you what the fuck down you
have to pay taxes.
Get the fuck out of here.
Let's go up 15.
So Mitt Romney and his family,
um,
they came from this one sec in this,
they're heavily armed and they fight off the fucking towel or not the Taliban,
the drug cartels down there like they get kidnapped and Shit.
It's like extreme shit.
Like the whole,
the whole scene is like really dangerous.
These guys are like,
they have rifles everywhere.
They're gone.
They'll,
they're always worried the drug cartels are going to storm the gates.
It's,
it's really interesting.
I believe vice did a piece on it.
It was it a vice piece.
See if you find it vice,
it's pretty damn cool.
They,
I think they did a piece on,
I think that's where I got all the,
uh,
the original information from then.
I just kept looking into it.
Right.
But Mitt Romney's dad like always wanted to be president but couldn't because he
wasn't born in America.
You're right.
Like Ted Cruz,
Ted Cruz,
born in Canada.
That.
Fuck wait,
but he's running for president.
He's both American and Canadian citizen because his mother was American,
but he was born in Canada.
So like some sort of thing.
Were you born in a plane?
Shouldn't be allowed to present anywhere in Mexican Mormon war.
Yeah,
that's it.
Vice full length.
Fuck Dude.
Interesting.
Yeah,
they're at war apparently with the uh,
drug cartels down there and they get kidnapped and all kinds of crazy five-part
thing.
Seven part things.
Jesus full.
You can watch the full length thing.
I mean the advice doc,
I mean the warring Mormons sounds like a great band name.
The warring Mormons are playing Coachella next year,
dorm in war.
It's like the Mormon Guar.
Well,
I think it,
they were fine.
Everything was cool until the drug war came and when the drug war came,
I think they got,
they got fucked
because they're like,
oh,
well now this place that we had sort of decided to live in this super dangerous
and then we got to go back.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know what happened.
I know when when Mitt and his family decided to come back to good old US event,
having two wives sounds good.
You know,
just have one on each side of the house.
One week you spend one with one hape or theory on any theory.
It's like communism in theory is awesome.
Yeah.
Cause everyone just does their own thing.
And then all of the things are split amongst everyone and like,
hey,
you're a doctor and hey,
you're a mechanic but we're going to take care of everyone.
And,
but the,
but it sounds great.
And then you get human beings into it where it's like,
okay,
now the doctor who went to 12 years of med school has to be like,
well wait,
I'm being paid the same as the mechanic.
The fuck.
Well you know what?
Also to men,
like whenever someone has any control over people at all,
people don't like to be controlled at all.
And you,
you know,
you get one grown adult that has any control over another grown adult and people
resist and it gets ugly telling people what they can can't do with their
existence on this planet.
Right,
right,
right.
I don't want to hear that.
You,
you,
you will be a mechanic.
You will be a carpenter.
You will be a tailor.
That's why Cuba doesn't work.
Communism doesn't work that way.
Not like that style of dictator,
communism,
dictator driven communism where they did decide what you're going to do,
what your occupation is going to be,
how much you can make and socialism in general,
like the idea behind it is beautiful.
We all contribute.
We all become a part of this community.
Meaning in a way you're small family union.
You're a small family unit as a communistic state because you're all like
helping each other out and you're all doing your jobs and wife on Sheridan
together.
That's very communist,
right?
Absolutely.
Piling all your money together and sure and then,
but no one's telling the wife like,
you know some bitch you got to do this.
Yeah,
this is his rule,
but I guess you are kind of,
I wonder if there's going to be any way that you can test for what you'd be best
at though.
Like the website 23 and me,
it goes through your DNA and it tells you like if you have the warrior gene,
if you have like all these certain genes,
uh,
if your kids are going to be bald,
but I wonder if there's ever going to be a thing where they go,
you're going to be really good at math stuff.
You're going to be really good at it.
But even if you are really good at it,
like say like if something comes along and says you're going to be really good
at math but you really want to be a musician,
like who the fuck is to tell you that you can't be a musician?
Dr Ken,
perfect example.
Dr Jiang.
Yeah,
Ken Jong was a,
was a doctor.
Yeah,
like really recently and go and it's apparently really good doctor and he's
like,
you know,
I was doing this acting thing and doing comedy and I like that better.
I'm making a good living at it.
I'm going to do that instead.
And he's funny and he's great at that.
I just think there's a lot of people would like to do a lot of things like,
look what if someone told me that I could either be a cage fighting commentator
or a comedian,
I couldn't be bolt right or have a podcast.
You know?
Either you do a podcast or you know you do something else.
That's it.
One or the other.
I'd be like,
Whoa,
how come park and just do it all or you can like,
I got tired of fuck you want to do man,
that's the beautiful thing.
One of the most beautiful things about life is people deciding what they want to
focus their energy on and then you see the fruits of their labor.
Like someone who does murals,
like they can just decide I want to do really fucking cool murals or someone who
makes music or someone who writes books.
Like you could just decide and when you got someone telling you what you can and
can't do,
that just becomes all fucked up man.
Yeah,
it's the,
it's,
it's the reverse psychology thing.
Where are you?
Where are you almost go?
Like you want to go against it,
like even if it makes sense just because you're like,
Eh,
I don't like you telling me to do that.
Oh yeah,
man.
People just,
it's not a natural aspect of,
for some people it's natural.
Some people enjoy being told what to do.
Some people guidance in their life,
they,
they like it.
And then there's also some people that like being ordered around,
there's like dominant and submissive people,
his people that enjoy that.
And there's nothing wrong with that either makes you happy.
That's fine.
Freedom man.
Freedom to be submissive is just as much of a freedom is the freedom to be free.
You know,
freedom to be an artist.
Freedom to be a doctor,
which fucking let people figure out what their thing is.
He didn't from families,
man.
I mean,
how many fucking people like I know a dude and his family disowned him.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
His family disowned his sister because his sister didn't marry a doctor.
He's the dad.
Put the girl through nursing school with the hopes that the girl would marry a
doctor now and she'll,
she can be a nurse just so she can marry.
So she's going to marry a doctor,
like dad's of total piece of Shit and the dad disowned her and uh,
because she married some fucking mechanic or something like that,
she fell in love with some regular dude.
This is,
the world is filled with stories like that for awhile.
Uh,
my parents told me that I could only marry a dwarf because any tall woman would
only want me for either a sick fetish or for fame or for money or something like
that.
I mean,
they,
they've,
they've since changed their tune.
But uh,
did you bring up Peter Dinklage she's got a regular size gal.
Yes he does.
And uh,
no.
They like,
okay.
You said that was the eyebrow raise
like the tall women.
I like him.
Why not man?
If they like you all right,
why not?
And that and like I have shelves in my house.
I would love to get used.
Yeah,
get up there.
I'm using ladders.
Exactly.
I would love to put things up at the fancy plates tonight.
Waiting enough,
the fine China Sea,
those baked beans at the top shelf,
go grab them.
That I'm missing that.
Like that's like that's dwarf porn.
Dwarf porn is just watching people reach shit and you're just sitting there
like,
Oh God,
I want to do that one day.
That's so do you worry like as a standup that there's going to be a certain
amount of like dwarf jokes that way you'll,
you'll hit like a wall.
Yeah,
I do.
I mean,
but the thing is,
is this your first special?
Yes.
This is my first hour special.
I've had,
I have two albums out and a,
and then this is the third special or the third hour that's being put out there.
What are the album's out,
uh,
called?
Uh,
got them.
If you want to get them on iTunes.
They're called Brad Williams coming up short.
And then the second album is called High Ho and uh,
yeah.
And they're available on iTunes are available on my website.
[inaudible] dot com if you weren't from my website,
I'll sign them and send them to you.
Oh,
look at that.
It's worth about 5 cents more.
Uh,
so yeah,
and,
and but the thing is,
is that like my jokes are always going to have a little person perspective
because I don't know how to write any other way.
They're not necessarily going to be dwarf jokes.
Like,
Hey,
I can like,
like isn't this weird?
I wear this size shirt or whatever the fuck.
Like it's not going to be w w I always use this example that a guy told me to
say on stage.
He's like,
I wrote a joke for you.
I was like,
what's that?
He goes,
you go on stage and say you can take a bath in a thimble.
It's going to be hilarious.
And I was like,
all right,
thanks.
Oh good.
So,
so that,
that's like my example of like the chief of like the cheesy dwarf joke.
Um,
but no matter what I do,
no matter what I experienced,
it's always going to be through that perspective simply because I don't know
what it's like.
If it's that different to experience things for through the,
through the eyes of a five foot eight guy.
I don't know.
I'm not familiar with it.
I don't know if it's different.
It might be exactly the same.
Do you think that you'll ever get to a point where it just doesn't even,
we get addressed,
like say if you become a famous comic and you're,
you know,
20 years in and you're,
doing specials on a regular basis,
like every two,
three years,
everybody knows who you are.
Everybody knows what you do.
I will,
I will.
I would imagine because it,
because right now it's at a point where when I go on stage I have to talk about
it cause the entire audience is like,
Yo what's this?
What's,
what's up with this?
I got,
I got to know cause people aren't that familiar with little people.
Right.
It's an experience that a lot of people aren't necessarily and the,
and there's a lot of nuances to it that some people just aren't quite aware of.
So,
and they have a lot of questions.
So I go on stage and I addressed those questions.
Uh,
but I don't want you to think that my entire act,
it's just like 12 joke.
No.
Like I go into an out,
right.
Yeah.
And there's only,
there's only so many things that,
that,
that you can cover right now,
uh,
in the new hour them try it that I'm trying to get together.
A lot of the jokes are just like,
this is what my life is like.
These are the stories that happened to me that are weird as fuck that you
wouldn't need that you're advertise person wouldn't even consider and you don't
think about.
And it's not necessarily like,
ah,
if I fall off a curb,
it's a long way,
man.
You know,
it's not like that.
It's just like when a dude got like when I won't do the joke,
but like a guy,
I got into a car accident with a guy and he got out and when he saw me,
he didn't give a fuck about the car accident.
He was just like,
whoa.
All right,
let's talk about this.
And he started asking me questions like about being a norm.
Was that a normal thing for you that happened?
Yeah.
Like people have that uncomfortable.
You didn't know him?
The fact that he wasn't angry about the fact that I fucked up his car,
I was like,
whatever you hit him.
Oh,
it was totally my fault.
I was texting while driving like,
oh fucking idiot.
Never do that.
People my fault.
Um,
so yeah,
I wrecked his car.
Like he didn't care.
He's like,
dude,
this is awesome.
Like you just start talking to me about being a little person.
I'm like,
whatever.
Whatever distracts you wrote,
it's fine.
Just showed up.
Yeah.
Like bizarre phone books taped to your pedals and stuff like that.
I have a pedal extenders,
so it's kind of close.
So it's like metal rods that you put on at you attach and then you put that,
have a pedal on top of it.
Brian,
don't you remember that dude who drove us around?
Oh yeah.
In Texas.
No arm.
He had no arms,
no legs heal nubs arms.
And he drove us around.
We had a car and hand controls or watch video of,
yeah,
we have video.
Just show 10 and I believe has that available.
Can you people on Youtube?
Yeah.
Wow.
See if you can find that Jamie.
We'll end with that.
But yeah,
he's,
he drives around with his elbows and he was like spinning the steering wheel and
says the is the mother of invention.
Yeah.
There was a trip.
It was a really good dude.
And he was drunk,
I think.
I don't know if he was drunk.
I didn't breathalyze them there.
I'll look at that.
Yeah,
he's got the nubs.
I forgot about him.
That was
his defense.
Yeah.
He just slips out of it.
And uh,
this guy drives around.
He drives us around in his van.
Wow.
There's a part where it right after here where he actually shows up driving,
I think.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then his other friend,
what was the weapon with his other friend?
His other friend was paralyzed.
He was in a wheelchair and he was heckling and he wouldn't stop heckling.
So I taught a girl who's in the front row with them how to choke them
unconscious.
So she choked the dude out calls.
Is it a cap city?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Comic Club in Austin.
Yeah.
I,
I recorded my first album that,
that place is awesome,
man.
Kid Park.
So is this the guy with no arms recycling?
Yeah,
no,
this is his friend.
I Adam,
shut off.
The only way I can think of,
I talked to his friends in the trophy room,
unconscious was with him and I said to her how she could get him to take a
choke,
choke him out.
Well,
yeah,
she eventually did.
When you left.
I coaxed.
It's ruined.
Yeah.
Kind of all about this.
You right or left,
squeeze that mother fucker.
You know,
you have to be ruining his show and the audience is encouraging to lose
consciousness.
A woman who just showed her tits to choke,
a man who's in a wheelchair unconscious,
she put him out.
That's hilarious.
You're lucky that dude didn't die like sue the shit
that they're looking at us.
He says,
yeah,
it was a valet gonna utilize that equipment.
Oh Belize.
Fucking hate me.
It was fun man.
And Yeah.
Would you valet your car?
No.
Like I like I pull up and I just go,
dude,
let me do it.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Right?
Like they probably would have to have her knees up way high.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause like I've got my car,
I've got my seat at the perfect spot where I can see the mirror steering wheels.
Good.
I can reach everything.
It's good.
And then the valley gets it and they just fuck it up.
So I,
so I just tell him,
Hey,
I'll pay the valet fee.
Just let me park it.
I'll come out.
Like just do that.
Or there's certain cars you can use and certain cars you can't use,
like certain cars you can't adjust properly.
Like the car I have right now,
I've got a Lexus CT,
which is a little hatchback hybrid.
And uh,
I didn't have to do too much to it.
I got Pedalec senators on that that were very small and then the seat moves up a
lot.
But also their steering wheel extends out.
Uh,
so I,
my arms are good cause my arms are small.
But uh,
yes I was able to grab the steering wheel.
I can drive that thing with not too much modification.
The only thing I had to do was I also had to pop the air bag because I'm really
close to the steering wheel.
So if that,
so if that airbag goes off,
it takes your head off.
Yeah,
I'm gone.
You ever seen people's faces and they get hit with that airbag?
The airbag fucking looks like give you some black ice and it looks like they got
hit with a waffle iron.
They had like those lines on their face.
A good way to put it.
Yeah.
And,
and I got to list to you,
uh,
based on watching that video.
Uh,
thank you.
Because you treated that guy and his friend like an equal.
You,
you,
you're just like,
no,
you're in the front row.
You're your buddy's heckling.
I don't care that you got no arms.
Well there was 300 other people in the show that he was ruining it for people
that have to deal with and you,
and we could all agree on this.
When you're doing a show and someone is heckling you,
it's not just you,
this person's fucking it
up for you.
They're fucking up for the whole room.
That's why everybody gets angry at them.
It's like people don't understand that.
Like there's this thing like you're trying to put on a show.
Yeah.
When someone jumps in like that,
like that person needs to be stopped at all costs.
Yeah.
I like when I get a heckler.
It's why I like,
some people say when a comic would go on stage and they get a heckler and then
they get like,
oh,
but this woman was heckling him and then he said that she should go get raped by
a thousand Dick's.
It's like he's not thinking or she's not thinking what's politically correct at
that moment.
You're only thought is shut the fuck up
as hilarious and also reflect the attitude of the room.
Right?
Because the room,
they're fucking angry.
They want to say something like that,
but they can't.
Right.
So you're the voice of that.
Yeah,
they're 1520 rows back and if you say,
I hope you get raped by a thousand decks,
they don't really think that.
No,
but that's when you violate the agreement.
The agreement is I to come to a show.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the agreement.
You come,
you're an audience member.
You're not a part of the show and not interrupting bits that are planned out in
advance.
You're interrupting time and you're making it all about you.
You're a selfish fuck.
And I hate that excuse of well,
you should be a professional party at his job.
That is part of the job,
the job fuck up.
That is part of the jostle.
But the idea that you should be a professional meaning that like this is like
you should just deal with it and you shouldn't say anything mean yes,
but without saying anything controversial,
you don't even know what this job is.
You have no idea.
I think that just because they paid money to come see you,
they can sort of dictate how you do it.
Well,
yeah,
it's the same way with the same way with the movies.
I paid money to see this x men movie.
It must be to my liking.
Cyclops is wearing the wrong outfit.
Cons,
cons,
Avengers.
Right.
Interesting.
The next one I got to remember.
All right,
Brad Williams.
Funny Brad.
Uh,
on Twitter and your special is May 8th,
May 8th,
Brad Williams,
fun side,
which is really soon.
It's like this week cover today.
This Friday.
Yeah.
Today is the sixth.
Oh two days away.
Showtime,
Brad Williams.
Uh,
and then the other ones are available on iTunes.
Just do a Brad Williams a search or go to Brad Williams comedy Dotcom.
The,
uh,
the podcast that I do with,
Adam Ray is called about last night.
Uh,
mister red man is a guest on a very future episode.
We've had most McCarthy,
we that Bob Saget,
like we've got a lot of cool people in there,
hopefully in the future.
Joe Rogan,
uh,
and uh,
and,
uh,
listen and,
and I'm really glad I finally got to do this because like I said,
you're years ago,
I hated you may know having never met you and now and now.
I hate it.
Never hated you,
dude.
There you go.
I'm glad we got together too.
That was fun.
Thanks buddy.
Grab Williams.
Ladies and gentlemen.
See You fucker soon.
Bye Bye.
You've never been on a bullet.
Oh,
I've been on.
Okay.